the 2020 u.s senior championship
features 10
of the strongest chess players in
america over the age of 50.
over the course of nine rounds some of
the most decorated players in u.s
history
will do battle for the prize fund of 50
thousand dollars
this field of accomplished veterans
which includes 2019 champion
alexander shabalov has racked up 13 u.s
championships
27 world open victories and numerous
olympiad appearances between them
championship dna will be on full display
in a tournament where every participant
knows what it takes
to bring home a major title
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
championship october well we're done the
u.s girls junior and
the 2020 us junior what a wild ride that
was
and now we welcome you to the 2020 u.s
senior chess championship which will be
held over the next few days
i am super excited about this one
i am jennifer shahadi and i am here with
grandmasters yasser sarwan and maurice
ashley
to call this event and its storied field
of players
well thank you jen as always a pleasure
to be alongside you
and to call the action with maurice what
a treat for me
it feels like a reunion of old foxes
and let us find out if these old
warriors have kept some of the
competitive spirit that brought them so
many
illustrious championships maurice this
is something special
absolutely yes and legends never die
and these are indeed legends of us chess
how many championships you've seen
between them 20
30 years ago they used to tear up the
tournament circuit
they were like gangsters when they
walked in the building
now we're going to see if these og's got
it and
show their their old magic that we're
going to get to enjoy
well let's take a look at the roster
here players donation
well our roster includes our two top
seeds actually with the exact same
rating if you're wondering if this is
going to be competitive grand master
larry christensen style a little
different
one might say than grandmaster gregory
kaidana
but there's also igor novikov there is
alexander shabala
our defending champion also excited to
see patrick wolf in the mix
as he doesn't play a lot of competitive
jess these days
no not at all and i see shelby gets
seems like shelby must have made it as a
qualifier gem
that's right he qualifies for the event
so the underdog indeed
fm shelby apps but dreams don't die even
for seniors
absolutely and let's take a look at our
format jen
well if you've been watching any of
these previous events you'll be used to
our format which is
a 10 player rapid round robin with three
games a day
time control game 25 with a five second
increment
definitely give some time for strategies
in the beginning and then
some wild blitz scrambles at the end of
the game if there is a tie for first we
will have
playoffs and nice little prize fun of 50
000 very nice and our scheduled gym
three days of chats so today and
tomorrow you're gonna
enjoy a weekend of incredible senior
chess and then on
monday we finish it out with the last
three rounds and that potential playoff
so now we have maurice to talk to us a
little about
the incredible amount of accomplishments
we have in this field
indeed if you're a youngin you may be
thinking about fabiano caruana
hikaru nakamura wesley so
that's the top of the u.s food chain but
those of us who've been around a while
we know that
these players really used to be just
that legendary at the top that
accomplished
we see these 10 players here and i just
remember
looking up to all of them virtually all
of them on this list
wow i want to play like them and i got a
chance to play against several of them
myself but their accomplishments are
simply
extraordinary as we dig a little bit
deeper we see of course nine gm's of
course
they would have that many grand masters
in the field
but even more so other things that they
actually ended up doing first of all
five of them
were u.s junior champions i'm not sure
they're remembering those days
going back four decades or so but yes
half the field
had shown that promise at a very young
age
to be sure and in addition to that 35
combined titles us open and close
championships
35 that's a heck of a number and
people saw these gentlemen walk in the
building and think oh my goodness
guess who's going to win or at least was
a favorite to win so just an
extraordinary
number there and we should also note
that we have five hall of famers
absolutely and maybe you might even see
a couple more
coming out of that list well just
incredible
accomplishments and this is just a
partial list by the way of the many
many accomplishments that they've had
let's drill a little bit deeper into a
couple of these players
as we look at big ladder larry
christensen 64 years old he's been
residing in cambridge
massachusetts for quite some time it's
quite some time three times
the u.s champion but he's got so many
accomplishments as well larry famously
jumped immediately to the grand master
title before ever becoming an im
just one goal bang and he won several
junior championships as we've mentioned
he played nine times for the olympic
team
and his style is just extraordinary he's
got books called
storming the barricades and rocking the
ramparts
so you know what kind of chest he brings
to the table it should be
incredible to watch him and another
player who plays slash and burn
is alexander shabala we call him shabba
53 years old how did he get in the
seniors
pittsburgh he lives in pittsburgh right
now he's the defending champion
he's won the u.s championship four times
seven
times u.s open champion four of those
by himself no ties and he has that
aggressive
tactical go kildam style he's from riga
from latvia
the school of mikhail alexey sharon
those players bring the fire on board
and that is indeed
what alex always does an affable guy
but not on the chessboard you sit in
front of him he's thinking only one
thing
where's the king i got to get
that slashed and crushed and ripped
apart
i mean i'm so excited to watch these
players play it's going to be
absolute fun
and jen let's take a look at the first
round pairings
well we've got a big one in round one
we have a seven time u.s championship
matchup as joel benjamin who's won three
titles
is playing against alexander shabalab
who has four titles
and you know we might see these guys in
the middle of the cross table in this
event but
no mate don't make a mistake about it
they win
when it counts and that's why they have
so many titles
um also of course i'm looking forward to
seeing gregory kaidanov and patrick will
play
and see what wolf brings in to the uh
the action from his
um many years of switching from chess to
finance
yes a hedge fund management and drill a
little deeper on that 50 000
prize fund for us jen fifty thousand
dollars at stake here
including twelve thousand dollars for
first eight thousandths of a second
remember that this event was originally
planned for the beautiful saint louis
chess club and while i'm sure the
players are sad not to be able to attend
in person
it's really wonderful of the generosity
of the sink fields and the st
louis chess club that the same prize
fund is offered for
a three-day online event absolutely
and maurice talk to me a little bit
about this time
time uh escape control i want to say
these players are used to playing
classical chess
over the board and when they're playing
online they're playing three-minute
chess and bullet chess
i mean i've got a feeling they're gonna
have some difficulties
adjusting to a 25 plus five
time control it can't be all ten of them
for sure that a couple of them will do
quite well and adjust quite nicely
as the games have in fact begun and we
see there joel has played knight f3
against chava but they
you'll see that i think as a key to this
event
the players who adjust quickly to this
world of virtual chess
online chess rapid chess with a little
bit of an increment
mouse slips dare we say all those issues
might come in
not because they haven't played online
chances you said they play casually
all the time right the issue will be
in a tournament setting this is just
simply
different for them to be playing in a
u.s championship
and then be the first time i think any
of them
will have played a serious rapid online
event i may be misspeaking there but i
don't recall
any of these players in any big time
rapid events
uh maybe maybe some of the blitz events
that have taken place in the past and
we'll see whether they can adjust
well there's a lot of blitz events blitz
tournaments chess.com
ho's regular monthly uh blitz
competition but rapid
competition online no uh
just it doesn't happen so we'll see
how the players do knight f3 g3
um well i i think of these like cagey
uh openings i didn't even didn't joe
write a book like
foxy openings or something i i truly
think you're right
yeah and he's he's like
very cagey in the opening knight f3 c5
by the way just let me take that back
knight f3 c5 joe benjamin much of his
career was a
an e2 e4 man and if he wanted to play an
open sicilian this was
shibala's invitation for him to do that
by playing g2 g3 he's
basically saying no i'm more like i'm
willing to play
catalan maybe a reverse grunfeld kind of
thing and with the move g7 g6
uh shabalov is saying okay but are you
going to play in
english uh or are you going to play the
c2 c3
what would we call that and d4 as uh
rever well uh symmetrical grunfeld i
want to say with g3
yeah that would definitely transpose in
that direction but without c4 on the
board
you said c3 d4 we saw some moves just
get
flicked really quickly quickly yeah when
the players
that when the players did decide on
the address of the king kingside
castling by white then very quickly we
saw bishop
knight c6 come as well now here is the
problem that white has
if he tries to play e2 e4 and play for a
fischer attack black has the flexibility
of playing
his knight to e7 and i don't think the
king's indian fischer attack
ever gets going if you play for c2 c4
it's going to be very hard to get in the
move d2d4 especially if black
puts a bobbinic pawn structure with
d6 and e5 so it really i mean i hate to
say it but
you know essentially uh
i think we're a favorite to seeing some
type of variation like the one i'm
showing on the board
which as we know is a pretty even steven
kind of battle
could we go to a game that has got my uh
my interest one of the underdogs in the
event shelby gets
you know that the players will be aiming
at him saying okay you didn't used to
rub
shoulders with us at the u.s
championships and
the olympic teams and the like may not
have the same level of respect but
he's here he's qualified to play in this
event and i'm sure he's
he knows he's got the target and he
wants to do well but look at this
opening position you don't see this one
every day no e7 e5
in this so we've got a chagoran with
knight c3 um used to
knight c6 but e5 so
if we take obviously attacking the
knight that really
forces if you will knight takes and it
does give
white this opportunity to gain some
space in the center
and that what is what yerimo did he did
take and the players have just played
knight takes d4
um jump in here jen are you familiar
with any of this
uh not to my eyes no no this looks like
a really fun opening though
as certainly um alexa malinsky playing
against the underdog who by the way he
qualified via the national senior
tournament of state champions
so that wasn't a place last year in
orlando
um shelby gets from maryland um
won the event as as an underdog in that
event
and here he is well
uh we we we do have our grandmaster
analyst various occlusion who points out
that there's been over 300
games wow line um and
not just did you say 300 games 300 yes
in this line with e5 mm-hmm
well you know exactly
clearly hiding under a rock i mean me
too
i've i've been under the same rock uh
maurice
and feingold played this three times um
lost
twice and had one draw um we played this
twic three times with black
okay ben feingold i wonder why he's not
here is he 50 yet i think he's about 50.
yeah no i mean he's definitely eligible
yeah
yeah definitely eligible probably he has
a pretty high rating he's good at
rapping and blitz he would be scary in
this field wouldn't they
yes he would i i was watching
uh ben stream and uh he was disappointed
that he wasn't
playing he was really hoping that he
would be playing he i think he mentioned
on the stream
that he needed one player to decline
their invitation and he was in g2 g3
that looks
like an awfully tame move to my eyes uh
g2 g3 what
i mean the bishop really belongs on g2 i
wasn't sure i
liked e3 e4 gaining space and after g3
shelby immediately said okay let me
develop
and now your mo is thinking because
if you let black just go bishop c5
castles this bishop will find good
squares
on the diagonal and black will have free
and easy development we can easily
imagine
excuse me we can easily imagine this
knight ending up retreating
either voluntarily or through a kick to
the d6 square looks pretty good
um i don't think g3 gave black
any issues it was a nice
guess by shelby g3 only played
once by it's once
out of 300. i'm still reeling at that
extraordinary number
i look at this position and i think if
black can get away with this of course
you'd play it
all the time oh maybe definitely a
surprise
weapon being used here and speaking of
surprises
we know that that patrick wolf
i mean i've known patrick for many many
years i was actually his second when he
was playing in the interzonal in beale
way back in 1993.
he came oh so close we our preparation
worked against dreyev and patrick didn't
kill him in a crushing position he was
trying to qualify there but
patrick known as a theoretician when
he knew his lines he knew his lines down
and he won two u.s championship titles
here he played an early b5 i'd like to
go back to move
six when he played this move b5
after d4 as gregory was doing this
double fee and keto and patrick said
well i'm gonna do it too
but this time with a pawn advance to be
able to capture
on c4 i dare you to exploit it and
gregory just left it alone i mean you
see a move like that on the board you'd
like to do something
more aggressive about it but gregory
said okay i'm just gonna
play straightforward chess no tactics i
i trust you on the dag and all that you
worked out
the variations and i think patrick got
to steal
b capture c for free because he got a
pawn from the side capturing a pawn more
in the center and then later
he even got in the move c5 so just
chipping it
chipping away at gregory center what's
wrong with black's position
absolutely and the move a7 a5
included as well uh that's a really nice
move because as you were talking about
this
structure uh a2 and b3 are
you know this pawn on a5 does a really
nice job
at restraining uh the queen side
majority
in this position at that pawn we're on a
nice normal square like a6
b2 b3 b4 would definitely be having
white's attention
and uh well black looks like
he's cruised a little bit past equality
and he's doing very well in my
estimation
you mentioned the interzonal in
beale did you say nineteen
three 1993
because in 1985 i played in the blade
of gersonal uh interzonal in beale
i was second behind uh rafi
vaganyan raphael vaganyan so when you
said deal
in arizona i was like what were you in
the field
i wouldn't have been invited to be his
son okay but you were
i was too weak for being 85 right right
but i was a little bit better
later later it came up yeah
i'll be there oh sorry no it's okay
shelby did you say i was just so
fascinated by this game because
uh yeah black was doing so well
it's unusual and this move bishop f5
now that to my mind is an incredibly
ambitious move
why because it basically says
i'm threatening to play knight c2 i'm
provoking the move e2 e4 and if i
provoke e2 e4
i want to maintain my knight on this
great square on d4
white previously could have kicked it
away now
after this move e2 e4 this knight is
rather
tucked in it settled in very nicely
bishop g4 always a nice little move to
disturb the
the white queen try to provoke the move
f2 f3 those pawn weaknesses
the pawns don't move backwards queen d3
was your most choice
and c7 c6 uh once again what can i say
uh shelby's position looks great
just simply and i was i was going to say
earlier as the structure was was
settling down
that pawn on d5 the only argument it has
is to say i restrain
the pawn on c7
it can't go anywhere it may be captured
and that's the
argument for having this nice pawn on d5
but if black gets in the move c6
then black solves that problem pretty
readily and now this pawn on d5 has to
be mindful because
it could be undermined and we see the
move h3 has been played
it could be undermined and then black
would try to figure out later how to
attack this guy
it's good that knight on d4 is so rock
solid
and white has not nearly completed
development neither has black
but white has to be careful bishops
jumps into the game leaps into the game
from f8
and castles easily as we see bishop
retreat to d7
and then black is just talking
initiative all day i'm also worried a
little bit about the move
b5 at some point i mean you you've got
to feel like
this is the position shelby can't
believe he got against the germinator
exactly they're used to kyle uh yermo
the
yerminator combination of your mo and
terminator
knight f3 and that to me is an
indication that well
things really have not gone white way
for example
if you well hold on knight takes e5
so i want to do it in the fall i want to
get this position i'll show you the
position i want okay
as black's captured just like you and uh
put the bishop on d6 where it not only
defends the spawn on e5 but it really
blockades the pawn on
d5 that's very important in terms of
this bishop on g2
so i mean i'm seeing this nice majority
on the king side for black
nice center majority for white he's got
the passer already on d5
that passer is not great in fact it's
firmly blockaded and it's not disturbing
black's piece development we can see
that black will
very easily castle and well
the only thing i would look to prevent
would be a future
bishop g5 and again i'm very satisfied
with shelby's position let's just go
around the
round the tables uh jan and uh
we're going to take a peek of the game
between igor and novikov
and the big c larry christensen
yeah that's the nickname huh yeah
merry christmas i used to joke with
larry
that he reminded me of babe ruth
that he had the body type of the great
legendary baseball player but the
difference
between babe ruth and larry is like when
larry swung for the fences
he might hit himself
[Laughter]
and sometimes knock himself out but if
he ever hit
you with his uh tactical uh bat
you weren't getting enough i don't care
if you were karpov
or kasparov or anybody larry carried a
very big
formidable tactical uh battle axe
didn't he famously beat karpov in 11
moves
yeah with a double attack right yes
queen d1 was the move white played a
retreating move that carpet
hitting two pieces of bishop on d6 and a
knight on h5
yeah we all remember that because it's
just like that idea that you could beat
karpov in kenmo
well it got a little worse because he
was staying with me at the time
uh i was living in amsterdam and he came
and stayed with me
so i asked him about the game and he
said that
when karpov resigned larry said we want
us
you want to go analyze it
did i say that i said larry you didn't
say that to anatoly karma
he said
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah larry would
would not be invited to another
tournament in europe
ever again after something like that now
let's see what we've got here because
first impressions are kind of a
favorable for larry
uh he is playing an isolated queen pog
clear
but from larry's perspective
all of his pieces pretty good
development
pretty harmonious this knight usually is
on c6
this time it's on c5 larry's just played
the move rook c8
uh in a sense positionally threatening
to play knight e4 and this queen
is rather on the long wrong square if
you play a move
like queen b1 you got to be a little bit
worried that a bishop on f5 doesn't show
up and chase your queen
even further my first impression is that
uh while it's a well it's a balanced
game
uh larry has the easier play i mean this
he's just it looks good this isolated
queen pawn is not under any duress
and is really very well defended in fact
so okay uh let's continue uh our
we're just checking on joel benjamin by
the way it looks like he did
go for uh kind of a king's indian
defense fischer attack we'll come back
to that let's check in on
uh two awards uh dimitri garvich
and alexander golden i always had the
impression that dmitry gervich
was one of those players like joel
benjamin
that played in and i'm not joking more
than 20
closed u.s championships
wow bishop f4 okay we've seen this
approach the queen's gambit declined by
magnus carlson
in this 2018 world championship match
versus fabiano
a lot now alexander of course all of
these guys are very experienced
b7 b6 this old move
really is considered second rate and the
old timers
all thought that c7 c5 was the right way
to play
so b7 b6 let's see if dimitri could take
advantage
of golden's
approach now queen takes does offer the
pawn
on bishop takes c7 bishop before check
it's a well-known gambit
where black gets a lot of nice
development
at the cost of a pawn but dimitri said
no i'm going to stop bishop b4
and i'm going to quickly put pressure on
the c file
c5 takes okay that
does not look like the critical move to
to my eyes the critical move would
probably be rook c1
intending to develop with the tempo of
bishop c4 he took
takes rook c1 and
white has
an etch an edge because of the
better pieces the knight on a6 is a
little awkward
and also the king the better king the
king precisely and the better king
that's exactly what it is and i for the
moment i think
that uh alexander has to be a a little
bit careful
that this knight doesn't just get way
late for a long
long time by this move b2b4 now what
what right right what is wrong with
knight c5
well knight c5 what about b4 and rook c7
does that
well b4 would uh yeah i definitely
feel like i've got to do something to
stop
rook c7 how about a7 a6
oh okay and after pawn takes c5
pawn b5 pawn b6 and you're just going to
take on
a3 with the bishop
and now after work c7 it's it is wild
isn't it
yeah you are giving up upon your oh i
know
that you have a great position anyway
and would jasper take it
i would probably take it uh recognizing
that i'm going to be
like i i'm a favorite to sacrifice an
exchange
on b8 because the bishop is actually
already
set up on the f4 square so what if i
just work g1 and bishop e5 we are kind
of getting into the weeds there
sorry but i just no it's okay i was just
curious about how after
in this position bishop e5 it's actually
difficult for you to defend
g7x oh you could just play g6 i guess
it's not that bad in this position
well i mean you have forced me to weaken
a lot of dark squares around my king
yeah right
so this is in one interesting line after
knight c5
b4 are you forced to play a6 there to go
in for these forcing lines where are you
what do you want to say in this position
the worry that i had for black was
the position after bishop g2 rogue g1
in this line and i i think we're going
in the weeds but they're
not now the same line you were just
analyzing
there and bishop is the move e4
is what i was thinking instead of
no instead of bishop e5 first we don't
need that tempo just yet
to first play e4 and test the bishop i
just want to know what you're going to
do you're going to give back
the pawn by playing bishop c4 and then
white will say okay now i'm actually
even material
and i've got this past pawn that's going
to hit b7
with force and there's nothing you could
do about that and that's what's going to
happen
right and or are you going to play the
crazy bishop
a2 well actually bishop a2 i can
i can almost force no i actually can't
instead if you play bishop to a2 what a
weird
that's it that's a weird one he's just
asking for it
but i see that b7 could come and again
there's so many great tactics
for white here that to look at it looks
like white should have enough
yeah favoring white for sure this was
like fun
after knight c5 b4 are you right that a6
is forced
if you don't go a6 if you go like knight
e4
um what about knight because if knight
e4 rook c7
let's see do i have any any way to like
play like knight d2
and wiggle my way out of this somehow no
it doesn't look like it there is a move
that
that's possible but it positionally
looks undesirable is the move bishop a6
after b4
and you're back to the same problem back
to the bad night
yeah is it the end of the world
i don't like having a night on that
square that's for sure
it's just one of those things that uh
uh white has got this very free game you
were mentioning jen when you're kind of
adding up the scales there
white's king is already on e2 it's
in the action you could easily imagine
that if all the rooks got traded off
white's king could quickly uh poke its
head out
and head to the c4 square whereas
black's king is still
you know the laggard it's way back so it
just just feels like
a lot of things that are happening in
the position
are favoring uh dimitri at this time
by the way we always used to call
dimitri not dimitri dima
dima was his nickname um shall we go
back to
uh the game of the seven champions yeah
that's exactly what i was going to say
you said it was a little you didn't say
boring but you said balance but
it actually got extremely imbalanced
gazer with um
some really interesting b5
uh this is the the this is the you
the we called it the king's indian
attack that bobby fisher made famous
from his
60 memorable games book um
b5 uh joel did not go for the
immediate e5 he played instead the move
bishop to e3 attacking c5
in a sense provoking d4 which
closes down this bishop's diagonal and
joel said okay
now that this bishop's diagonal is
closed i'm going to go for a different
setup
and i'll put my knight out here on the
a3 square
and sometimes it warms its way back to
the b4 square
let's see how shabba said give me more
space
and we have
caught up with the players and well my
take is
i like black i prefer black's position
i've always
liked the advantage that having a lot
more space brings
and it just feels like joel has gone for
one of these
counter-striking um
setups where there's no obvious weakness
in white's camp right i mean it's not
like
hey i'm gonna target you on g3 or i'm
going to target you on e4 so
it's not like there's anything that is
there for
shibala to attack it's just that well
again he has freer peace play he
his pieces are somewhat more active
thanks to this pawn and
a little bit from white's point of view
white is still
going to try to be playing solid
something happened in larry's game that
i'm not really thrilled at
to be honest is the exchange of
dark squared bishops it's
it's one of those positions that it's
not much
uh if anything for white but white wants
to see the pieces get traded off
why wants to see more and more pieces
leave the board and this trade of dark
square bishops
if if white can just get a lock on that
d4 square then you need to say
let's trade some more and some more
actually i didn't expect knight takes on
e4 on the other hand because that does
allow pawn takes although
novakov will be able to put a knight on
d4 it will be unassailable on that
square
but i get the feeling that black is a
bit more relieved
seeing this piece seeing this capture as
this pawn
can fix itself i don't think you're
going to see night takes
on e4 and it looks like he's played pawn
takes
knight to d4 and this situation a bit
different reminds me of an old kappa
blanca game
maybe maybe it's alekhine alakan playing
with the black pieces
classic games where black is able to
just keep everything solid and now black
could somehow trade off the light square
bishops and get that d3 square and be
smiling
yeah and that's it though uh marie said
that
highly desirable trade at the light
squared bishops is not going to be easy
for black to execute because bishop c4
will just take twice and it'll cost you
a pawn to make that trade
in the meanwhile this bishop on e2 does
a great job
at keeping this knight at bay um
the pawn on e4 no longer an isolated
pawn but
nonetheless kind of a a worry there on
e4 and if it provokes f7
f5 well i don't know
that could be there could be an issue
with black's king
are you worried about that pawn yes i
mean the guy yeah
like three different times when you spot
the weakness
miles away it's it's it's actually not
defended that many times
uh strangely enough if it was white to
move exactly in this moment
i think a move like b2 b4 with the idea
of
munch is coming so um
i do see an easier
play for white rook is either going to
go to c3 or c2 the other rook is going
to
come over and well
no where are the targets for black right
uh larry might might dream of playing a
move like queen g5
intending bishop h3 there you go that
might be the way to go
in order to execute a trade of the light
squared bishops
maybe it's queen g5 that larry is
considering here
you know that's what he's considering
it's larry christensen
queen migrate to king i see king i see
king
that's larry christensen and that's
where his brain
will be but look at this he just decided
to make a liar out of us
and trade off the knights uh
knight b3 positional mode larry getting
more
position though well well what am i oh
i'm missing knight d2
sorry you were so after that pawn you
wanted that
yeah i was so after that pawn on
e4 that i overlooked the fork
knight to d2 winning the exchange
on f1 and that's
fine that just answers that which
means white needs another approach
now i mean i hate to say it this looks
very very
even uh
maybe white's for choice because black
has a lot of pawns on the light squares
but um nothing more i think i don't
think it's
it's enough for now meanwhile somebody
who's getting something
is the underdog of the tournament as
shelby gets
um is currently i thought he was up a
pawn
he is you're right one two three no
it's four against four oh excuse me
what am i doing when i checked earlier
but maybe
um maybe not now after hd4
oh because he won the [ __ ] the pawn on
g4 but white won the pawn back on c6
okay because i was looking at like
taking on d5 and then capturing on g4
so i thought he was gonna win upside but
for some reason he didn't like that line
maybe there was just like a fast d6 or
something like that so he
instead went for this um and now the
pawns are equal
well the pawns may be equal but there's
a big challenge
in terms of the bishops and i'm talking
about the dark squared bishop
because black's light square bishop very
soon could be kicked off the board if
you put a knight on f5 for example
uh maybe not it's actually now that i
look at the dynamics i don't want to
release your bishop from prison
that's sitting on g2 so this would be a
big thing in this game
maybe kng7 wasn't the best move
considering that
i would have wanted to activate my rooks
as fast as possible
even potentially at the cost of a pawn
seems like i could have just just been
active rook d8 rook
to d2 seemed like a very
sharp way to play to accentuate the
bishop in this position king to g7
i can't say now that after a knight will
land on f5 you're probably going to have
to take that knight
and then the bishop on g2 gets more uh
money than it's
worth uh in this position
not easy to see exactly what yerma
should do
himself he played b4
b4 i really didn't think he had the time
for him i was like rook d8 just trying
to play rook d2
yeah exactly well i mean
if white's intention was to try to
try to go queen side with something like
b4 and a4 and b5
uh this bishop to my eyes is just
dominating matters and as
white i'm not even happy uh playing
knight f5 and four single
opposite color bishop trade i think that
black is for choice in those types of
positions
shelby however against before
he said you know what you have only one
good piece
let me trade it off i'll play rook c8
and
undoubtedly shelby's idea is that if you
play rook c
one i'll trade and this time i'll grab
the d
file and f2 will be unprotected
so it just feels like shelby is
continuing to nurse an advantage that he
almost claimed
right out of the opening i find it a bit
strange though that he put
he played rook c8 with the opposite
colored bishops that
will come soon you want to keep rooks on
the more rooks the merrier so this
this may be okay but it feels like it's
taken away
some of his advantage in my opinion
because you know an up
unless he plans not to take on f5 and he
has some way of
dealing with that knight but it feels
like the knight's going to be too strong
and f5 that trade's going
to happen it's just no way that trade's
not going to happen
so it seems like he should have kept the
more pieces on the merrier even though
he can argue for a little something here
but the weakness is only on f2 it feels
like in this position
here i can play something like bishop
back to a4 so i can put the bishop on
the b3 square and then you're only
attacking this pawn
the king can move
i don't know there there's a bit of
weakness but how do you bring your king
up with f7 hanging
well no matter what it is it's a two
result game right yes certainly
certainly well okay step by step right i
mean that's
already uh quite a nice start from
black's point of view so
like if i was black i'd play rook v2
making sure
to keep the bishop uh let's say
inhibited
and i would start to reposition my king
a little
f7 is hanging now so and then you want
to give that up the bishop will land on
e6
yeah i'll trade i'll trade the well
doubled f pawn the that that f pawn
really was not
a big factor f7 i mean and if i can put
my king on f4 and i'll reset my
rook no i'm not saying it's a win
no no no no no but i do say two results
two results
yeah i like the i like the rooks on the
board for sure just either
yeah i think maybe winning chances that
would have been preferable but just from
a psychological point of view
being outraged by every player by two to
you know 400 rating points or 300
rating points two to 300 rating points
is really difficult psychologically
because if you lose your first game you
just have these nightmare scenarios
going on your head
what if i lose a second a third or
fourth so it's really good for shelby
psychologically that he's
gotten off to a better position with
black
with with hardly any losing chances
definitely
i i i i i i want to give him some uh
some kudos just let me let me give him a
little love right here
because after the move b4 he played rook
c8 b5
was yermo's idea that was why he played
b4 anticipating
that any rook trade at least he'd get a
pass bomb shelby said you know what
i should have played rook to d8 yeah a
moment ago
and i really do like the fact that i
prefer
pawn to b4 from b4 to b5 because that
means
that you're not playing a4 a5 and
disturbing my bishop bishop is
monsterous
that is really a nice little nuance so
i mean i i'm i'm also worried about an
attack on the white king a move like
rook to d3
threatening the possibility of taking on
g on g3
and if you trade you do open the g-file
and other rook might park itself over
there
and you know you got to watch out for
tactics even in that line as well
so there's some trickery but we've got
to shift to another game and that is the
game between
patrick wolfe and gregory krydanov there
was a move that patrick played on move
16
gregory by the way has sacrificed a
piece but on move 16
this move knight to d5 caught my
attention
right there it's not often you see these
nights
these four nights in the middle of the
we say called four nights various
openings after four nights
but the four nights like this d4 c4 d5
e uh d5 c5 and so the move e4
then happened we go one more move and
this knight shifted
over to b4 and you wouldn't guess that
it was the f6
knight that migrated all the way to the
other side of the board so now you see
this knight is being very active
trying to get its way and gregory played
a couple of moves to just keep
everything under control he played
bishop c3 and after queen b7
he played rook cd1 getting away from the
four queen a6
h4 h5 and then he said it's time
you're wow your chickens uh or
the rats away or the cat's away i guess
i'm trying to get my
my proverbs in place
knight f5 lands on the board
what a move tactics of course
is he hanging a piece is an e7 check
patrick took it
capture on g7 king takes queen check
king
to f8 and now queen h6 check
and it's what does he have
if there's some i mean it's amazing
variations
if king e8 or because if king e8
knight e5 looks like 95
or so 95 you're threatening
mate he can he can walk the gauntlet
with king
d8 i was wondering maybe 95 isn't it
maybe e5 is it yeah yeah d5
well maybe something like this with the
idea
to go yeah you can undermine the
structure
of you know e7 and d6 are great
but if i get to play f5 f6 now or
i've already got one pawn i flushed your
king into the center of the board where
my rooks are ready to really make a a
a very nice concerted attack now don't
forget i can also play
um king g8 because kinneat's you know
very aggressive it's like
i'm trying to what am i trying to say
that i'm not actually trying to win the
game and avoid a
obviously you have a perpetual um but
you
want more what do you do okay so you
play pawn takes half f5
well e5 with with uh the threat on the
night and
um the exchanging of queens that would
force queen g5 jack
exactly i would definitely certainly
would
well let's count people let's just count
there are
one there's only one pawn at the moment
so white has to be
very careful uh if ta if king g8 takes
do you want the per pet rook d5 is not
on tap
knight no sacrifices look like they make
any sense
we see patrick wolf uh just
looking a little bit nervous there i
kind of
kind of saw him uh by the way is it
completely
ridiculous i mean in four penny and four
pound kind of thing
there there is
i could be queenie to check
with rook f2 here my dream was to be
able to take
and play rookie one and again it was all
about the king and the center board but
that's
a lot of this is that's a lot of things
to do for you it's a lot of wood
but there are threats right and this is
exciting this rook
rook is attacking the queen uh you do
have
two pawns for two nights but patrick's
excited he didn't want any parts of that
crazy position he wouldn't put his king
back
to g at least once to test his opponent
do you want to draw do i have a draw in
my pocket
or right because exactly queen g5
but again is there is it no pawns at the
moment
it's zero pawns at the moment at the
moment for the piece right
right so i i'm trying to set up
the old familiar standby checkmating
patterns
uh one idea was to oh
can i do it another way look at this how
about this
how about this is a crazy uh the
beautiful thing about commentating
is if we don't like something we can
just take our move back
i mean you know i get to sacrifice all
of gregory's pieces and if i say oh it
didn't work it didn't work that's too
bad
and no i don't think this one's going to
work either i think that uh
that uh my checkmating patterns are
are are well don't forget a knight can
go to e6 so easily that
you're yeah
yeah um yeah hmm okay
gregory's gonna have to work it out but
he did say he's the one who sacrificed
the piece
b7 rookie five in that position okay
sorry i was here here here
what did i do i went something like this
you went
there i went there i went there rook e5
now we're talking there you go
that's a big stick that's a that's
actually a killer
that's a that's a blow yeah that that's
but
i don't believe it i don't believe it
this is awesome
i love the spirit of it but man
[Music]
remember the coffee coffee house
being compared to a coffee house player
yes
[Music]
you're not the you're not the one who
who is uh
keen on sacrificing all the pieces and
we do see a perpet
practical decision occurring yeah
yes and our first result that would be
then of the
g of the senior championship um as the
other games all look
quite rich except for that game between
um
christensen that you mentioned earlier
and novakov that seems more likely
to end in a draw but the others are
um very rich including joel's game
against shabba
that one hardly any trades on the board
as is
typical for the king's indian attack um
as the
the clock start to tick down i predict
some fireworks
in the time scramble yeah this game does
have that feel you know there are
certain games that you just have a sense
that is it that they're going to be
decided by the time scramble
this has that about it it just feels
like both players are still
kind of jogging for position and feeling
unsure about
themselves i really like what joel did
he got in this doubling on the c
file early so it really limited uh
shabala's maneuvering ability in the
meanwhile he's also
look at that he's so pretty he's so
clever he's great
i mean nike is a real threat yes exactly
f6 and h6 precisely that's a real
and you know he's trying to lure this
move he's trying to get
this and that's a real concession
because now
joe can reset and go after the g5 square
put his bishop on
h3 and start to target this pawn on e6
in the meantime it just feels like the
queen side is frozen
very important strategically for those
in our audience
who might feel that b5b4
they would really be attracted to this
move ah not so fast
this knight on a3 is actually kind of
stymied
and by allowing knight c4 strategically
white is really really happy uh
with this outcome so the move b5
b4 this looks like a great threatening
move in fact
it's got a big trap written on it and
it's not a move that
uh shibala should play uh five minutes
to three minutes we're gonna have to
keep our
eye on this one oh yeah oh yeah nice
play by joel
but who knows what'll happen when the
clock starts ticking down
but yeah let's check in on uh getz who
um was uh definitely on top of things
against alexandre marlinski our underdog
performing so well
exactly and he did pick uh
pick your pocket there maurice for the
move rook d3
you mentioned going after the knight
threatening rook takes g3
that provoked knight f5 check now here
was a very key moment
uh shelby took and that's okay he uh
but because knight e7 isn't forking a
rook on c8
i think serious consideration had to be
given
for the move king g6 here and just bring
the king
up the board and just let the knight
live oh
yes yes interrupt but i was confused i
thought that there was a perpetual in
the gregory
patrick game but now i'm seeing that
actually it's still underway
and oh he did the sack reagan sacked
another piece
oh he did he did the sack he's gotten a
position
he went for it and patrick had
did patrick have to give up the rook
what was patrick afraid of
the oh he was afraid of oh no there's
easy i mean queen g5
probably draws easily when you think
about it right because
he can easily get in queen g5 and and
queen eight
six if he feels like it in the worst
case well yeah as
is saying if he thought it was just a
draw he wouldn't have sacrificed on v6
he must have thought he was lost in
those lines
but what i'm wait a second who wouldn't
have soccer you
black wouldn't have sacrificed well yeah
queen v6 here
right so what i'm saying what i'm saying
is you have to play this move because
okay because white has all the options
in that position
if you play if you play queen moves then
queen g5 check
uh okay so you can play like this so
queen g5 check
and in the worst case
black is drawing a white is drawing
easily
and in a better case he may be playing
his rook to h6 like you did yes
and say well you know you sure you're
alive
i mean this this is very very dangerous
to have to play you're going to be
walking the gauntlet larry christensen
would be looking over at this board
so maybe get my book write my book again
as
you can go to the second chapter put me
in coach
let me in coach uh yeah real quick go to
d2 knight can go to d3 you're right the
the black king is exposed but the
problem i'm having
is after rook takes d6 queen takes
there's no question for me that the
queen
is out matching the two knights versus
the rook
the problem is i already have a couple
of couple of pawns in the pocket
but once i play this capture your the
black king
is basically toast so yeah
there it goes and i mean this pawn on
f6 is just it's monstrous and
i think that patrick went into a lost
position i feel this is a losing
position for black
but by the way the game between gats and
euro malinsky
was a draw so yermalinsky um
saving what looked like a very dangerous
position but
really well played opening by shelby
gatz who
gets the monkey off of his back drawing
with black
in the first round in a tournament where
he's a big underdog
absolutely and had real chances to win
the game too by the way
that's very very well done in that game
i agree with you guys the the fact that
this is the resulting position that
patrick gets
versus versus the other position that it
wasn't clear that the game was over
over right this looks very very bad
like very bad too easy for white to play
right
you know exactly g4 g5 g6 or
maybe well it's like one of those things
that
that
that that all white really needs is just
some way of opening up the g file let me
just play
and you play a bad move and i play a
move and now you can see what i mean
uh the the black king will just get
flushed
but you don't have to play this way uh
unfortunately
uh from gregory's point of view uh
black can play rook to the seventh rook
a7 to h7 and just show his kicking
prowess e8 trade
queen versus three pieces a queen versus
a rook in two nights
i've done a study of these types of
material imbalances
and the key for the queen that well the
key for the
for both sides is generally all about
the past pawns in the position where are
the strong
pawns of course the king exposure
matters
but where are the strong pawns and white
has that mass of pawns on the king side
and we'll try to make good use of that
to hold
black's pieces at bay that night on f8
will probably stay there for quite some
time
so if it tries to get into the game then
there's going to be a lot of exposure to
the king
and that h pawn could run down the board
or actually the g pawn
as well so that's a challenge if those
pieces could just get coordinated though
then you'd have something going but
usually you'd rather have a bishop and a
knight
on the board than two nights they don't
do as good a job
especially with an exposed king so that
one is going to be very tough for
patrick but there's still some technique
that needs to be done
novikov christensen was a draw and
meanwhile the game between joel and
shavulav does rage on
as shovelling that thing's been traded
and this one
made the move rook d8 guys um and it's
joel's move
he's been spending thinking for two
minutes a pair of pawns traded only
and he's playing before i mentioned
knight g4 was a threat earlier because
the knight f6 would have forced the rock
now he can play knight f6 it doesn't win
material but it still
lands a night on a juicy square and he's
done it
knight f6 check what happens if king g7
white's winning
what just happened of course this knight
on f6 is
monstrous okay you just play the move e4
e5 and just think about those fischer
attacks
where you never ever ever ever get a
knight on f6
and you've just got complete domination
here uh
shabala shabba has done something
extraordinarily can we challenge
the knight i guess no you mean with like
you don't have to wait
for four to d5 you mean something like
that be
be careful not to allow uh oh sorry
uh bishop c6 bishop b7 looks if you're
not
gonna play b4 then your bishop doesn't
belong on a6 so
bishop b7 looks like something you have
to do is there a knockout
below how do you ex well the eighth
queen
actually the the a5 pawn is also hanging
i know you want to put your queen on 86
jen i was doing the same thing
shift over which is why i want to put
the bishop on b7 so i can move my knight
off of
the e7 square and challenge your knight
on f6 maybe knight g8 for example would
be a
proper way to do that the the key here
however i'm going to push back a little
bit yes i think white is sure definitely
better
i mean maybe even winning but that night
on a3
does does being a bit of a poor picture
40 seconds to a minute so this is maybe
that's the main point maybe we're busy
yapping about
position and it's really about the clock
somebody's gonna block
give me a move you're telling me your v7
wasn't he wasn't just play bishop b7
26 bishop b7
and he's played bishop seven he's played
maurice's move although i'm a little
worried about something live
is another move okay i will just go
bishop g5
personally and just say i mean i'm just
killing because i've got 97 kind of
ideas after a trade i mean on c8
b5 is weak my knight is actually useful
thank you
rook c rook c5 your queen d2 could come
into play
as well yeah that was you know it was
funny i wanted to put my queen on d2 my
bishop on c1 like you guys
saying go go to go to h6
that's a cool line like if i play queen
d2 and you play knight e5
joel has 19 seconds oh my gosh
sorry i'm sorry to jump in but he had 19
seconds he just said let me move my king
like that's the reality in this position
16 seconds to 23 seconds this is
ridiculous
look at this scale middle game with only
a pair of pawns traded off
and they have to do it all in 21 seconds
with 14 seconds
there's a blunder waiting to be played
oh yeah oh yeah this is going to be
about a blunder of some kind
and now more likely for black because
white's position is so juicy
it's easier to blender for black that's
for sure shovel up up against it queenie
for
22 seconds for oh that the five i was
i was wanting to do because now the the
no
isn't this guy here night f5 played by
the way by by shabba
and queen he got it into that square
that that maurice and i were looking at
so he
so he could have taken two pieces for
the rook look at alex
did alex lose on time or did he just he
didn't resign after queen f4
but it says one zero for joel it says
one zero for double
well he would not have resigned no he
must have flagged and the
the lead chest is not showing it yet
we'll find out guys meanwhile
um golden this is terrible yeah by the
way dimitri
diba was i thought winning a bishop
of the same color ending
but now i'm not so sure how am i going
to get my king
across the rubicon and into black's
territory
i can play a4 one day
but one is dimitri grovich versus
alexander golden
and that looks like black will just
ignore it and he'll just move his bishop
oscillator's bishop between c8 and e8
keeping an eye over the h5 square this
looks like a draw
patrick will gregory kaidanoff let's go
back to that
that one's kind enough mopping oh that's
over there's too many pawns
well i said it was all about the past
pawns you were right
man wow there's like four of them
oh my goodness that's the last time
you're gonna say you were right in this
broadcast yeah
no no no that's nice those
uh those pawns really made all the
difference
and patrick well i'm i'm sorry to say in
this position
you could maybe remove all of
white's pawns except the apon and you
might still be
just winning on the spot exactly
uh it went do we have other games going
on because this went really fast when we
left it i think
that's it yes this is our last game
mopping up with those quartet of pawns
against the lone knight
wow that's a lot not the lone night
there's a pawn too
but it's not doing not going anywhere
not fast enough
yeah actually this looks like a really
very very nice game
by gregory okay
that decision is pointed out by patrick
not going
not going for the draw and here he he's
hoping for a trick
uh hope that somehow his pawn can get to
f
one but queen a1 looks like that's all
she wrote
knight e3 93 queen f6 check give me your
opponent
and you're done so that's the easiest
path probably to victory
so look for this one to be over he's
found another one queen a6
same thing stopping f1 but also
having queen f6 in mind if he feels like
it
if your night moves the king is moved
one more move just to see these guys
don't give up
you know we need to check we'll make you
give up
you will stop the clock there there'll
be no hope after that
great victory by gregory very nice yeah
really nice nice some nice games
knight f5 gregory kaidanov sacking
pieces
sweet well
we got two winners right now we got um
gregory two victories
and joel benjamin were the two victors
both with the white pieces
both nice games one game um kind of
abbreviated because
definitely joel was playing great but it
looks like it ended in the time scramble
did we find out yet how that happened
we'll find out for you on the break for
sure
but um it seemed to me like he must have
lost on time and it didn't register
yeah unfortunate way for that to finish
the game of the round was definitely the
game
of gregory's beating patrick the knight
f5 go for it kind of move
uh that that position was wild and
woolly then he sacked again on d6
i mean you've got a double knight sack
in that position guys
how often do you see that happen not not
a lot of times
and gregory by the way as great a player
his
as he is he has never won a u.s
national title very strange i mean that
just seems so weird
given how many titles he's won over the
years never won a u.s national title and
i'm
thinking he wants to score one he's got
to do it
sooner or later it's going to happen
right now in a good position starting
off the first game
that's remarkable thinking of all the
times he's been on our u.s olympic teams
i i was sure he had won a national
championship i'm sure he's won
countless uh you know really really top
uh i'm
open absolutely but
here we go hey our production
happy birthday keeper very
always great to work with pj whether it
is in st
louis or virtually and wow look at that
camera guys
that's some impressive looking technique
heavy heavy quite
technical wizardry always keeps us
running smoothly when something dramatic
that happened in the studio
something's going wrong get key day in
here
it's always calm yes
but you know we still owe him you know a
big
you know i don't know something because
we were having a staff party
at the kingside diner and we did some
karaoke you myself and
and ben feingold did karaoke
alejandra akita started taking some
video
and he said don't worry guys i'm not
going to use it and then he used it on
us so we owe kitten environment
yeah he got to do something
he's the guy he was the guy that
captured that
i thought it was momo and the supremes
what what what did they call it
i think they call it momo in the gms but
alejandro doesn't want anybody to to go
look at that one
the dancing
and we will have a break and we'll leave
you with a little
a little chat between the three of us
and we'll be back
on the other side with round two of the
senior chess championships
[Music]
kovid 19 has obviously interrupted
all of our lives some say maybe for the
good
some say maybe for the bad but one of
the things that is really happening
from the covet is online learning
and um playing remotely this online
learning jennifer are kids learning
more or less comprehending
more or less well for for chess which i
can speak to
i feel like it really depends on the kid
uh i interviewed uh grandmaster irina
crush for
my podcast ladies night and she talked
about how strongly she believes that
you need to also in addition to looking
at screens you need to really
make sure that you're using books and
real chess boards and that
she has lots of young students and she
notices again and again
that they plateau if they only study
using screens
so i feel like the kids who are able to
discipline themselves to create a mix of
both
would really excel in this time where
they're able to
you know be so efficient but for some
it's very difficult
and it depends on your personality type
like chess players are lucky because a
lot of us
um definitely not you two but me and
many other test players
fall more on the introvert scale i'd say
so they can
cope with these terrible times a little
bit more easily
but for kids who are more extroverted
this is just like really harrowing
not being able to meet your friends and
you know see everybody
more often and and learn in between
those moments so
it's complicated times but on the
positive i think when it's all over
we'll take the good stuff from the
online learning and then add back in
all of the stuff that we're lacking from
being able to see each other face to
face
it's a curious thing for me as you
mentioned in terms of
being more extroverted i would say
thinking about my growing up years part
of the fun was going to the park
in new york and meeting all those great
people playing chess
and being able to play with them and
hang out and rap and talk about life
and that was part of the growing
experience in chess that was part of the
fun of it
is why you wanted to do it it's a bit
more isolating to think of
being in a room by yourself all the time
i did that too by the way
i was reading books and i'm doing it by
myself but it was so that i could go
back to the park
and kick everybody's tail like that was
the fun part is not just being
stuck in the house all the time so
i can see that being a challenge for the
fun part of it being able to socialize
but of course you do have almost
unlimited
access online and it opens up a window
that's completely different
you think about it yes you know you're
playing in seattle i'm playing in
brooklyn
well if you're in seattle we could play
each other online
and it's a whole different kind of
experience entirely
yeah and for me i must say that
i've been more busy now during this
pandemic than i have
in years before so one of the things
that i've been doing
besides jumping in on various streams
and
doing commentary is a chessable learning
chess course just teaching
uh with this really kind of cool
platform this
uh learning platform called chesable and
i think
there's just so many tools that
have become more and more available and
taken
for granted and yet i just think that
these are phenomenal
tools that are going to make our kids
and everybody's kids
actually just a lot better chess players
jim
i agree yes because i understand like
one of the main
concepts behind chessable is this idea
of spaced repetition
and i just love the idea that kids are
going to be taught
and and grown-ups too a lot of adults
use this as well
that you're not bad or untalented at
chess if you don't remember
things quickly that just means you're a
human
and that you need to have a scientific
way to remember things
and i'm sure you guys had your own
systems
and you know yasser has talked before
about how he's blessed with a prodigious
memory
but um i i personally had all sorts of
systems flash cards you know
you know writing things down writing
them down in on notebooks also writing
them down on the computer and my chest
space files
and like i i had these techniques that
helped me memorize things but now
it's real science behind it and and i
love that that nobody
needs to think they're dumb if they
don't remember their opening variations
for the 20th time
they just weren't going about
remembering it correctly
well i forgot how good my memory was
[Laughter]
my memory used to be pretty good but i
also would like to add the possibilities
for kids
especially uh being able to access the
best players on the planet
in camps i did a cover story for
the october chess life november chess
life actually that just
came out and it was on the
young phenom abhimanyu mishra who
is the youngest international master in
u.s history and he's trying to become
the
youngest grand master in world history
and he's when he told me how many chess
camps he took
over the summer he took one with krum
anand
gelfan he took it with uh with
with um agar
agar jacob agard as well i mean he took
with so many people elianov he took it
with
it's like what week after week after
week camp after camp after camp
if you try to do that in person you'd be
flying all around the planet
meeting these guys in these diverse
places and all the kids have to do is
wake up
brush their teeth wash up have breakfast
and bam
you have elite gm's right there
in your living room it's beautiful
maurice and like my brother runs the us
chess school and he's getting you know
all the top players sam shanklin
you know he's got casa corley all these
great role
models for the kids to give these
lessons
the st louis chess club is offering
online programming
i think it's beautiful to see and one
other cool thing about it
is that it also allows for for adult
education for ongoing education
irena crush tata of abrahamia and you
know a lot of grown-ups are telling me
like yeah
i get a chance to study with kramnik
this is this is not normal
people who have regular jobs can take a
few days vacation
and suddenly work with aggard it's great
to think of chess as something that's
not just for kids but for anyone who
wants to put the time
and love into it
[Music]
that was an amazing piece of calculation
that easily dominated his rivals winning
game after game the opposition has never
been
as heated as percy
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2020
u.s senior championships as we go into
the second round we have two victors
grand master gregory kaidanov's
sacrificial victory against patrick wolf
while joel benjamin indeed reconfirmed
one on time
against alexander shabala the time
scramble
did decide it chocolate's position was
in peril
but he fired pretty early on before it
became
a true back and forth scramble guys and
that could have proved dangerous as
the event goes on as these are very fast
time controls
um you know that base time of five
seconds is not a lot
the funny thing about shabalab is people
think well
he's such a great tactician doesn't that
mean great blitz player
the answer is not always right sometimes
the great tacticians need time to
calculate
and it's the great strategicans who are
the real blitz legend
well i felt uh ish shambhala never even
got a chance to land a blow
in that particular game he just seemed
way off
in his game and he didn't particularly
handle
the time control very well but now
having said that
we have uh the pairings for round two
jen
that's right and um we've got some great
matchups as always
um we've got gregory kaidana of our
co-leader playing against dmitry girvich
good friend of his
and then we also have joel benjamin um
black against alexander golden so
gregory starting off with his double
white
yeah nice to get pairing number one
yeah that's pairing number one i always
liked uh drawing that number
in these uh round robin events as you
just said you
you get to start out with two whites and
you get a black
in the last round as the
as the extra white you start with well
your responsibility of course to take
care of those two whites
and if you get off and the wind is at
your sails
right we'll see whether or not joel who
is used to winning national titles
whether or not that will be the case
good to start off strong in these events
you don't want to be trying to play
catch up
we saw in the junior event that just
concluded sam cevion
started off poorly and came on with a
bang at the end four wins in a row to
close
out the tournament you think somebody
who does that must have won the
tournament tie for first no
started off too poorly once he got
informed it was not enough
you want to be an early leader in chess
tournaments
that's just the rule uh jeffrey for
example was
was leading early didn't work out for
him in the end but he was right there
the tie breaks
that's the kind of position you want to
be in starting off strong every single
time
absolutely i'm just looking at the
pairings and
uh when a player starts with a loss
everybody just kind of turns and looks
and say
well you know how vulnerable are you
larry christensen will have a double
black
as he'll be facing off against patrick
wolf but patrick wolf had that loss
to gregory kaidanoff an inspired game i
would say by gregory kaidonov
it's what what cost patrick the game
but when the sharks are swimming and
they sense a little blood
let's see if larry can uh do something
in that game
and as for our tournament leader gregory
kaidonov
he's up against dmitry girvich i bet you
these guys could write
books on their games with one another
they played each other so many times we
see a very relaxed looking
gregory kaidan off there wasn't that odd
the contrast between the two
those those players patrick was in a
t-shirt
we didn't notice this or didn't remark
on it patrick is in a t-shirt wherever
he is the heat is
up gregory and it looks like the
interesting is that is that the u.s
senior t-shirt because it says senior
championships on it but i can't yeah
it is that's the swag
okay and i saw larry christensen
in the um hoodie
and but gregory's got the sweater on
wherever he is they didn't put the heat
up
in that place kentucky
heavy sweater on doesn't matter where
you are outside i mean
what matters is the temperature you have
inside right who turned down the
temperature control right
as gregory said i got to put on
something thick and look at that
the the books behind him big bookcase as
dmitry gorevich looks like he's got some
flowers and a nice little
um etching there behind him the
backgrounds of the grown-ups are
different than the ones of the kids
because the kids are usually living at
their parents house right
it's not always chosen by that
gregory i think is in lexington dimitri
i think is in chicago uh yeah they're
underway patrick wolf e4 and
larry opening up with the per defending
with the perk defense
uh g6 and bishop g7 a old old favorite
of mine
definitely shows he's in a combative
mood because the perk defense leads to
some very imbalanced battles
well bishop c4 is immediately for me
one of the most contentious ways of
playing as white as immediately
with his bishop on c4 white wants to
play e4 e5
and e5 e6 and he immediately
uh puts the pressure i want to say
becomes a very forcing line of play
this particular variation
shelby by the way is decided that he's
taking
his opponents off the beaten
path every c3
say what a three
move one whatever your preparation was
you weren't ready for that
no you weren't look at this a3 on move
one and
novikov said well i'm not going to put
my bishop on b4 so what if i just
fianchetto it
uh yeah
a3 go figure well we we would say
seizing the defensive in seattle it's
sort of like okay
you play e4 so after a3 if you play e5
as black then i can play e4
and you don't get to play the rui lopez
anymore
right because the pawn is on a3
uh but okay uh what can you say
i mean you got to do something and the
players
that's a bold move to play the players
have reached this position now
i would have been very uh reluctant
to play the move c7 c5 the reason for my
reluctance
is that there are times when white wants
to capture
when suddenly the move a2 a3 could
prove itself useful right because if you
capture and you follow it up with a move
b4
the pawn on a3 will be defending uh
before but uh igor said nah never
believe i'm gonna play c5 anyway
usually guys that's when the bishop can
go to b2 you get that extra move in and
then you put a bishop on b2
not when your queen side might get
vulnerable to an a5 kick
so yes he has to be mindful of that i
know exactly what you're talking about
though
so if he takes it uh what what what was
sorry the a five
uh for example let's say i play knight
to d7 in this position
i'd be d7 b8 d7
okay so while you're puzzling out this
position guys i have a trivia question
for you how many times has
one a3 been played don't tell me 300.
in in in in the database that volusion
has
yeah for reason okay i'm going to say a
thousand times
so maurice says 300 and you say no i'm
saying i wanted to say
less than 300 300 just because we just
slap whoever played it but probably
it probably is a high number 4956
wow that's orthotic
i wouldn't have guessed that no that's
five times the number
that i would have guessed i i was
feeling i was a little high on a
thousand i thought
maurice might be very low at 300 but
no i was making the joke remember
earlier
300 times i was just making that joke
but a3 on move one
yeah a lot of humor from players coming
to the board
may be drunk he said
i'm not prepared i'm going to put a
three on the board
a3 on move one better than passing right
like you'd rather
be white and play a3 than be black right
yeah i would say so i don't think the b3
square
has been weakened that much for you to
say a3 is that terrible
moon yeah no no it's a it's it's a kind
of a passing of the advantage
another alex versus alex shaba versus
yurmo
and these two players when they get
together you know they're going to make
something very interesting in the board
well
interesting started on move two mm-hmm
after e5 said i don't want to see any of
your berlin
defenses that you've been working on for
the last month or two
no no no i'm going to play the center
counter
and recapture with the queen and after
knight c6 i'm going to do something
off the beaten track queen c4 i suspect
there's upwards of a few thousand games
with the move queen e3
queen c4 for me is new territory never
never been here before g6
also very unexpected uh
way of meeting uh white's setup
knight c3 bishop g7 knight f3 and
if shaboliv gets to play bishop g5 in
castles
he will have a very comfortable
opening advantage right out of the box
because
bishop g5 castles this queen might look
temporarily misplaced
but don't forget white got to develop
for free
like exactly at this moment
it's two to nothing in terms of the
tempo
count right and it's now two to two
so if you get to go bishop with tempo
in castles uh you're going to lead in
the edge knight
g8 e7 on the board by the way
you said alex versus alex yes
and there's a story from yesterday
you're probably not following will
will smith no not that will smith
the two baseball players will smith
of the dodgers and will smith of the
braves and will
smith the hitter hit a home run
against will smith the pitcher
and the dodgers topped the braves
and everybody said well the real will
smith did stand up
in that one in this event we have
five alex's i didn't pay attention at
all
but we have alexander golden alex
caballo alex yermalinsky
uh oh no i'm mistaken
i double counted
i saw so many on the screen we only have
three alex's three alex's
yeah my my story was such a good story
until it fell apart with facts
oh well there we have an
igor number coughing out
by the way we do have uh again
i i will be very curious if varusian
could help us
and say how many times this position has
come on the board because we're in for
an exciting
battle here between the two alex's as i
do
see black castling short
that is to say castling kingside white
castling queen side
and we i just love these positions where
the kings are on opposite flanks
uh because it just makes for such
compelling attacks
by both players let's move d7 d6 it
is encouraging knight d5 i will wait
before playing at knight d5 personally i
would like to see
the move bishop e6 uh before
playing knight d5 i want to make sure
that
i want to capture on on d5 and
fork some pieces so we'll keep an eye on
that one we'll just go to the game
also joel benjamin uh leading after
one game with gregory kaidonov spying
against alex
alexander golden joe black let's see how
this game
open knight f3 while you're doing that
yes sir
may i may i ask do you guys have the
game between gregory and dimitri on
yours
on your board
and and okay we're hearing that there
are some technical difficulties
transpiring at the moment so the game
has not yet begun
between gregory and dimitri
okay i saw that uh as we were starting
our broadcast for the second game that
the two players seem to be conversing
and i was thinking
who's in the room with them that they're
they're chit-chatting and probably they
were talking to each other
probably they were having some
difficulties or to the arbiters yeah
maybe to the arbiters yeah okay uh
nothing uh to speak of right now between
uh joel
and alexander this is uh
well-known territory let's just drop
back to our game of patrick wolfe
and larry christensen that was the perk
defense
and that seemed to have some promise
when we left it we just seen the move
queen e2
as white is preparing to play e5
e6 in a hurry black plays c7 c6
and if the position looks like it might
have come out of that an alakan
yes i think it's actually
transpositional
to some alakine opening positions bishop
and the knight came to d5 to stop the
bishop from supporting
the pawn coming to e6 h2h3
preventing bishop g4 castles castles
and the players have reached
this position
now because i i see this knight coming
to
d4 and i think of it as such a huge
threat to play knight d4 knight take c5
that my first inclination is black
is to drop back and offer this kind of a
trade
and that way i got rid of my uh
problem bishop so i would expect
that and larry said no i can
let me take a different approach i'll
play knight b6
the problem with backing up is white is
not forced to trade bishop c4
is just an offer of a trade
but why would you back up let's say
wouldn't you i mean this is a trade i
think
as white i would embrace unless there's
an exchange sacrifice
but i would think that knight d4 is the
move here maurice
yeah that looks like an attractive move
if i can get the bishop to back up
well now the bishop feels a little bit
more comfortable
on uh on b3 now having said that
maybe i should actually try knight c5
maybe even this is a little bit more
forcing
because if the bishop does back up now
there's there's no c6 c5 in the position
and
this feels uh comfortable
for white no that didn't happen either
can't guess the moves uh bishop
did drop back to d3 and now larry said
hey i can exploit the moment to play
knight
oh there's a trick there's a trick what
was the trick
there's a discovery trick you have to
watch out for your your queen
is your queen is hanging so like
knight f or or knight c knight c3
ah thank you
ah boy blindness
and yeah the desired knight takes
e6 is met by knight takes e2 check
oops okay that clears some cop webs
thank you for that maurice oh my
okay shame on me so uh
knight b6 nice move
bishop d3 looks awkward i
b4 nice move by larry and it feels like
patrick has done something amiss with
his opening
the the bishop can't move yet again
because of bishop c4
oops uh
rook d1 is not desired
but do i have a does patrick have a
better move
than that maybe now he can play knight
c5 or
knight d4 the point being that knight
says you can still take on e6
yeah take anything well no it's not
there's a knight c1 right oops
that one i did see and by the way
patrick did play knight c5
so probably with the intention
of simply recapturing with his knight
on d3 but his pawn
oh and he did that yeah no
no no no if i if if i could get such a
position as black i'd be playing the
perk all day
long uh this is a dream french
no bishop d5 there's knight b7 right so
yeah back to c8
okay think of a french defense and now
imagine a french defense fantasy
right you get your knight on an anchored
square
and you have a good french bishop and
your king is safe
it's like you don't get those things in
a french defense usually
usually you got a problem either a
problem bishop
uh you've given up too much space or
your king is being
attacked here plus king is safe in this
position you're not worried about e6
no no i'm not worried about e6 one
little bit
uh you're missing your light squared
bishop yep
so let's see how i could take advantage
of that
um i am
looking at queen d5 it
sometimes we have this problem that we
have two
pieces that both want the same square
right and you know he was like you got a
knight that wants d5 you got a queen
that wants d5
and i'm trying to think you know how
which which piece do i want to occupy
the square first
let's try the queen while you're doing
that would you just say that
the game between kaidanov and gurvich
did commence
they're on move six for right now
nothing much to look at
we'll just stay where we are but they
did resolve whatever issues
uh very good confronting them and
they're off to the races
very good and we'll we'll drop back with
our game we'll come back to our game
with patrick and larry
and let's see after e7 e6 i was thinking
of the move
queen d5 maurice the idea here of course
i i take up residence on a magnificent
square in the center of the board
i tack this knight on c5
as well as this pawn and i'm hoping that
i get some position
where i've got a sacrifice brewing
uh against either h3 or
on f3 okay none of that
force there and that we d pawn seems
like he'll be a factor but he didn't
play it he played queen to
man yeah and none of this happened very
surprising
larry just played queen to c8 saying
okay i'm willing to uh
give up my beautiful light squared
bishop
larry's not one who likes to retreat
pieces by the way no
no no larry
larry has one mode and that's straight
forward there's this great story i don't
know uh i'm a
nfl football fan and there was a
campbell
uh a running back earl campbell
and the guy was a cannonball he just he
just went
forward and he did these drills and one
of these drills was a 40 meter drill
where you run backwards you run
backwards and earl campbell
failed the drill running backwards
he didn't do it very well and
the the guy says you know coach well i
mean you know
uh maybe we shouldn't recruit or earl
campbell and
and the coach said believe me erc earl
campbell
ain't running backwards
he went on to be one of the greatest
runners in the nfl history
larry christensen does not retreat he
doesn't run backwards earl campbell was
one of those guys where three people
would tackle him
yeah and he would take a fourth to
actually bringing him down one on one
leg one on the other leg
one on his back and you needed the other
guy to hit him so that he actually went
down
so no he's not going backwards and larry
is that kind of
big big liar mentality
go get him don't back any pieces up by
the way we need to
switch to an extraordinary position
where black is threatening big time
is the game almost over in 12 moves
shelby versus igor novikov
this a3 experiment don't try this
at your next chess tournament all those
4 000 games played
because it looks like well queenside
castles got him into a lot of trouble
because
look at this battery on the b2 pawn
right yes and the f2 was hanging
and the knight may be hanging on e4 you
would say but you can have it if you
like
you go ahead bunch away because taking
on b2 followed by bishop f5
that's gonna that's gonna hurt that's
gonna leave a mark
i mean look at the rooks sweeping into
the game at d8 and
c8 we got to try something like
queen b3 or queen b5 but then we're just
losing in exchange
i mean and upon yeah if we if we
if we um as you say jen just take a time
out and defend
against the threat of b2 then we have to
deal with the fact that we just lost a
pawn
and an exchange is being fought now back
here
no it's just way too no there's nothing
i was
i was i had some crazy
scheming dream of a knight e5
and stuff but no i mean even the queen
defends g6 so
this is just uh this is over
look at the pain on getz's face while
novokov is kind of looking away leaning
back
relaxing don't try no a3
on me i am i am a grand master after all
and that this experiment has failed
including that castle's queen side very
good point gin
c5 worked perfectly he took on d5 after
the knight went to e4 and he's just been
fully
punished for this play 12 moves in
pretty much it's pretty embarrassing to
have played this kind of line and now
realizing that you're going to just
drop interior yeah though once again
do kill me and i do believe
i am going to be uh killed
uh what is the most convincing uh here
well i was just going to play bishop f5
to start instantly
yeah i want to know what to do about c2
right i i didn't know if you wanted
bishop c3
check as a star here i i'm again i'm
just
probably just getting absolutely
mangled um well i mean you're at least
giving me the piece
back all right in that line so yeah oh
well
i would be i'd be happy
to some kind of an ending or any
thing i just i i was i was i was looking
for like
the the crispy cream right here
trying to defend if we throw in bishop
c3 check first forcing king e2
then your bishop f5 really looks like
that could be it uh because i'm dreaming
of getting my bishop to d3 before
that's a good you know like and this
i don't even get to play bishop e5 uh
this feels
got to be over no no no i'm not happy in
any way it looks like this is just a
disaster
let's just jump back to shabby and
irmo for a moment because shabby i don't
know if you just appreciate that
nickname oh
come on shack shabby
he's playing it's not shabby at all yeah
that's exactly what i say
not too shabby gabby i yeah i mean i
like the tradition
i like it okay that bishop on h4
um pinning the knight on e7 um
but the problem is no that's a very good
move
uh i wanted to say how
how is this pawn sacrifice
now we know shabbat is not backing off
of any pawn sacrifices when he can get
his knight to f5
and they don't have to be even more than
a pawn sack right
because you don't have that many places
to go if you play 97 knight g7 king d7
bishop e5 just wins a piece
yeah if i take your terrible bishop but
right
sorry say that again please maybe you'd
have to play like c6 here
but to protect the knight or knight b6
two two moves possible oh knight b6
right
knight that's a tempo that's a tempo
move yeah
so knight b6 let's say uh always look at
the most forcing lines
first and a move like knight v6 is
plenty forcing as
it does come with a tempo so are we
happy about the pawn sacrifice
i think so i mean queen d4 is that is
that a good move
let's see you play you play queen f6
here
yep knight yeah and knight g7
looks like you're putting on everything
here
i've got
wasn't the best mode is that the best
move because i feel like maybe
i had better queen of six is the next
move so we know
yeah given that queen f6 is the next
move we need to be ready to play
two moves after this one we're going to
take on g7 probably
yeah and maybe h4 so right whatever
whatever queen move that is it's
probably going to line up that way
unless you plan to keep your knight on
that square which i don't see how
when the queen lands on f6 where like
queen e4 right now
because the problem is queen e4 queen f6
the threat is
actual it looks like there's some threat
of moving the knight out the way and
hitting b2
man white's king side is coming under
fire in this this round
we saw getz's king side you'd get hit
that is where the queen side castling
now we're seeing
black try to do it here as well a lot to
think about
well yeah there's a reason why queen
side castling is the exception not the
rule
because it keeps your king more
vulnerable right you really need to play
the move king v1
but he's done it he's done it we're here
we're here he's got his king already on
c1 we'll keep an eye on this let's just
check in on uh the game of joel benjamin
joel benjamin
joel is sharing first at the moment with
gregory kaidanov
thanks to their victories in round one
and joel said you know what
this is a rather tepid boring position
let me spice things up
he took on c4 and
normally speaking as you heard maurice
uh in the first broadcast of
round one normally you don't want to
trade
a central pawn like the d5 pawn for a
wing pawn
so i mean this is definitely a strategic
concession
by joel but he did it for a very
specific reason he said you know what
i actually think that this pawn is a
target let me see if i can't
win the pawn bishop e6 and
well you didn't want to play c5 and
maybe allow the knight to c4
so knight d2 was
alexander's choi joyce and queen d7
hmm how do you like these apples guys
this is a
this is this is different it's black
i mean sorry sorry yeah
right you know i feel like that bishop
on e6
is blocking my potential um freeing
moves
and so unless i can get more pressure on
c4 i'm just not super happy i think
you're just
building this formidable center and i'm
gonna have to be on the defensive
okay but having said that to my mind one
of white's very very best pieces
is the bishop on g2 and uh
he's lined himself up to be able to play
bishop h3 force a trade and
potentially weaken white's king's
defense
so you're saying if e4 you'll just play
bishop h3 immediately
sidestepping uh the now e5
with the idea that if i have to go back
time out
to go backwards and nice right like earl
campbell
not knight e4 i mean
i get it that you're taking off one of
my big pieces but then i still have that
space edge
that's right you're definitely
black is definitely in a cramped
position but joel just looking at the
webcam
he seems kind of happy
i don't know if happy is the right word
he seems
fairly okay with his position by the way
yes getz decided
that he's going to give him an exchange
but he's going to do it
on his terms if you will he played the
move rook to d4
to deal with the the threat on b2
saying you want to give me your fiance
bishop go ahead
and novikov said yeah i actually do
yeah yeah that that was a creative move
no question about it now i guess he had
to take it right away
i mean there is the potential threat of
rook b4 because
you know with the pawn on h6 hanging
you'd almost like to play knight takes
f2 and take
the rook on d4 on your own sweet leisure
right
but he took it right away took on f2
rook g1
and now h6 is hanging but
nobody believe that black has enough
compensation
nobody pleases you no we don't
no no no we're going to have high class
trickery in this position
novakov only has 11 minutes left but he
just needs to figure out how to
consolidate there
so a big winning chance for him of
course yes
gov will try to milk that position for
all it's worth and we
did see the pawn sacrifice by the way by
shabalov that is now reality
although wait a minute he didn't take it
he didn't take it did he
not he decided not to take it and he
played
c5 talk i mean talk about going from
solid
give me the pawn let's see what you've
got to
no let's get wild yes c5
changes the whole structure and this is
shabala of country
h4 on the board now two bishops
but the unbalanced pawn structure and c5
charging
oh we got a good one guys yeah
this is a good one shaping up is a
donnie brook going on over here now
here's
a key key moment what whenever you're
white in such positions you really want
to play
h4 takes g5 and you want your opponent
to cooperate with you
and you want him to play him or her to
play h6
takes g5 so you can have the open h file
now of course
in this moment the move c5 attacks the
knight but this is the question
can we sacrifice
gotta ask it bishop there it is bishop
h8 looks terrible
after h7 check your this is the king
goes up and now queen the fourth running
[ __ ] should be five
yeah no this is a dream come true black
would
have to play in this position bishop f6
that would be absolutely
forced and now the issue is
serious you don't seem to be able to
break through the king will go to h8
queen takes d4 well you do have h7 and
rook h6
so if you play the knight is going to
move the knight is going to move to f5
right right so
you're saying that you can meet
jennifer's idea of pressuring
f6 well actually for starters in that
position there is bishop g5 check
if you're right yeah yeah so that would
be problematic
there is a reason why we tuck our king
into the b1 square
rook takes d4 knight f5 nonetheless
here i could conceivably check
maybe it's a little bit yeah that's
that's
okay ambitious ambitious and suspicious
sack right i mean no no no no no we'll
have a good position without sacking
like just move our knight and then we're
threatening you know takes on g5
with similar positions except we're not
down a piece and by the way
love doesn't have that character though
he shabbat love doesn't like when you
start pushing his pieces around
even 95 a rook b8 action might happen
no he did make a move guys he played
bishop bishop takes e5 this is
much more concrete if you will i have to
say i'm quite surprised by it but he
does take the bishop
off of that square where that knight f5
threat was going to happen before
but given given that bishop takes e5 is
so real and it's and it's been played
knight f3 and i didn't mean so you're
saying that a check is just a one mover
i play king b1
and then i'm turning g3 and you have no
stability with that bishop
well it's not that i'm threatening g3
this for me
jen is like i'm saying fantastic
when your bishop was on g7 you you were
scaring me
you were really really scaring me you
put your bishop on f4 not are you
not scaring me i'm saying your bishop's
misplaced it so happens that yeah you're
right i get to play g3 but i also
i am i'm right back to getting to play
h4 takes g5
and i think the bishop is misplaced so
this move bishop
e5 by the way i mean i
you have to yes exactly it's like
you know we are trained not to
voluntarily give up our bishops for the
knights like
you know our buddhist presses you know
you know i often say on the show
bishop takes knight is the most
important move most important exchange
in grand master chess and it's because
it's usually
counterintuitive as you say because okay
no
it's a bishop why why are you giving up
a bishop for a knight
when the bishop looks like you're gonna
have this nice long diagonal
but man the control of the opposite
color squares becomes a factor
and here the light squares white can
start thinking about attacking on the
light squares quickly
open the file put a bishop on d3 put a
queen on e4
and whoa whoa whoa hey where's he going
exactly he's going to h7 knight f3 and
we are
not seeing a very very satisfied aymo
because he knows
his position is really not good
like bad bad bad
bad this is not i love that move bishop
takes e5
what a great move and shabalov is
leaning back
let's get the body language he's leaning
back saying what more could i ask for
out of the opening
i've got the pawn on h4 i'm threatening
knight e5 his light square is a weak his
king is bad
my king is going to find a move c3 at
some point
and blunt the attack along the long
diagonal you're not gonna have anything
there this is sweet
yeah not only that everything you said
i'm
signed me up for the bishop in some ways
uh
could also go to b3 bobby fischer loved
to put his bishop on a c4 in a sicilian
and put it on b3
so that his king was extra protected and
this just looks
like shabbalov is going to have a lot of
fun let's go to the game between golden
and joel benjamin
when we left it the gym you were a
little bit
skeptical about your mo apartment about
joel's approach
and uh you were afraid that you were
going to get
cramped as black
we were looking at the movie for bishop
h3 but
um different attack by golden a
different approach you just started
pushing his a pawn forward too
you know highlight the fact that the
knight on v6 is a little misplaced then
you know maybe he will play
for a6 or
knight to c5 you know obviously i can't
do it in one move
either maybe via yeah e4
or a4 right so the thing is is
you know in this position black joel is
threatening to capture this pawn
on d4 if you pause
for a move like e2 e3 then you may have
to deal with bishop h3
and if you defend the pawn on d4 with
this
move knight to a4 uh the nice part about
that move is you
are threatening to land on c5 with a big
big tempo
and if that were to provoke a move like
b6 then i would say
okay i kind of feel like
white got in a pretty nice
strategical um advantage of
a big center and versus
you know uh a queenside pawn that may
not be meaningful
as the e4 pawn i think if white can
excuse me
if i can play e4 d5 he's going to have a
very big advantage here so
joel might be in a little bit of trouble
by the way e2 e3 was played
alexander golden said if you want to
trade bishops you're welcome to it and
i would probably trade bishops right
away you were mentioning jen the problem
with the space cramp that black didn't
have active moves
once you get rid of this bishop you will
be uh angling for e7 e5
type of moves and um counter play
hey you want to talk about bold play
yeah from your from i do i do
i'm laying on your back the game between
fm
shelby gets the big underdog in this
event we're just kind of counting this
one out
but yeah but take a look at this
position
go starting from rook to g1 if we go
back to that moment where black is just
cruising it looks like bishop e6 queen
e5
knight g4 get your queen out of there
queen at this grovel it looked like back
to the e1 square but that pesky pawn
hanging on h6 prompted the move g5 and
now the bishop had to drop back so it
just looks like
all your pieces are going backwards he
plays bishop at f5
going forward and shelby said i'm taking
the pawn on e7
good man open up a line you know
whatever you get the open file for your
rook or play bishop c3 rook f8
and now queen b4 he has a pawn for the
exchange
the bishop on c3 is his only hope to say
he has
something for it but it's it's bad
it's it's bad definitely but it's
doesn't feel like he was doesn't feel
like he was getting mated somehow
yeah yeah no no this could be over we
weren't able to look
at this game no no we were going to
suggest you know
you don't you know avert your eyes this
could get really ugly
i think white is kicking here
i mean yes of course you have a material
advantage and you have some initiative
but if you don't put white out of his
misery and you let him play
just a few consolidating moves
those are some good pawns that's four
versus two
yes and you're wrong and look at the
clock it's
ten minutes to four ten minutes to four
minutes no because
not having that same kind of uh relaxed
glances that he was doing before he
looks a bit more concerned
and he's not played a quiet a6 that's a
move that says i just need to make a
move
i need to hurry up make a move just it's
a useful one
but i don't think this is the knockout
blow that he wanted
at all and this could get strange
this could get strange it's a bishop and
a pawn for a row
well if it's a bishop in a pawn already
well now i'm starting to think
well let me just play bishop and pond
versus exchange
uh i hoping that you can't take this
pawn
maybe you can then maybe that's uh maybe
okay i think yeah
you're not getting anything back we're
not gonna i'm not getting anybody we
don't have to
in that case it's king d2 and bishop d3
to the rescue
and again a bishop in a pawn not
complete
compensation but 93 um
and then you still have bishop d3
that was the intent now you can play
night check but okay i'll take it and
i'll plant a knight on each other no no
no the opposite color bishop ending
starts to become work
that one's not not fun to play at all
you want that one
handed some chances absolutely
we'll get back to that let's take a look
at patrick wolf and larry christensen
when we left it i kind of like what
larry was doing
rookie won knight d5
okay knight takes
and yeah okay some strange moves going
on
uh looks like they want to trade places
you mentioned it before
the queen in the night when i trade
places the queen go to d5 and then i go
to e6
right right right you know like
everybody wants to use the square
um you in the game of joel benjamin i
was mentioning bishop h3
it's a way to trade off the fianchetto
bishop when there's not a rook on f8 or
rook on f1 bishop h6
can be met by bishop h8 and it's a
strategy i've used a lot
in my tournament practice but gregory
kaidanov
has argued that this is like one of the
most
overrated strategies by black you
preserve the bishop but
gregory will argue that the bishop on h6
is actually much more powerful than the
bishop on h8
we'll see how this works out for larry
bishop h6 bishop h8
queen f4 queen d5 finally i love this
queen on d5
i think that's a great spot for the
queen the knight wants to come to f6
and patrick wolf said no no
no i don't want the knight to come to e6
it will be very good there was an e6
good here
oh if e6 you could play that something
yes
well i thought um we could play e6
and that was why was played okay to over
protect that knight because knight g5
does carry that threat of the e6
f7 mate there goes that bishop on h6 so
helpful all of a sudden
exactly i want to move my pawn to e6 and
same thing exactly so that was why
larry played rook c8 but you kind of
feel
that this is a little bit artificial on
larry's part and he's going to be
obligated to play f7 f6
that's what he did yeah yeah
exactly e6 would
sorry john you're right and then knight
f7 would
just allow knight takes e6 exactly
oops that's a tempo
no no that was my rookie 3f6 on the
board
and here i've got to say
i'm liking white
i'm thinking that this bishop is really
really powerful
thanks to the fact that this pawn is on
g6 and not back on g7 so i'm seeing some
dark squared weaknesses
the knight is very good no question
about it pretty is a picture
but it's actually doing more defensive
work than offensive and i've been seeing
h5
on patrick's agenda and some
i think white is for choice well talk
about why it is for choice
the game with shabbalov and
guillermo yermo said i don't want to see
any parts of this attack
and he played a pawn sacrifice trying to
get bail out maybe into an
end game he put his bishop back on g7
after the move
knight back to f3 and shibala said i'm
taking that pawn
and after queen b6 let's go into an end
game queen to b3
i'm willing to just shut it all down and
after h
g5 knight g5 d5
and he's i mean we all know these
checkmates
h7 looks tenderoni is there a trick in
there
but it looks like there's no chance to
get in with any kind of weird sacrifices
rook h8 or something
wild no that's not going to be anything
there and queen
to h3 doesn't look like it quite
does it after the first check on b2
uh and followed by another check on c3
so that wait
is that the case what is queen h3 here
take king up and check
there's no there's this check and
where's your next check
or queen queen f4 or bb queen d4 was
another option
queen d4 bishop d3 and yeah
oh and then you can play queen yeah but
still it's made
it's still made right
yeah i was just thinking that i wanted
to try to provoke white's
king to step in front of the bishop and
i will
just uh sidestep that because there's no
mate the
the the checkmate and then i gotta
discover
in a discovery check that's the clean
refutation there because there's no meat
um but okay back back
where we are currently after d5
it it just feels like there's got to be
something
really compelling for white if
if there's nothing really really really
compelling than something like c2 c3
just preparing to drop back with the
queen
and threaten mate i'm
i kind of like that for white by the way
i mean he is a part
to the good queen takes b6
okay if i'm in your mo's shoes i'm kind
of breathing a little sigh of relief
right i was thinking that black's king
was a little bit more vulnerable and
after a b
i i do get to recapture with the tempo
and my pawn structure
well it's a little nicer than it was
just a
half ply ago by the way let's take a
look at the clock times as well
shabba has 540 and nirmal has 147.
you don't want to be the one defending
this position
down upon in all practical for practical
purposes
this is a two result game no matter what
and it's going to start to look like a
one result game
as c3 gets played to locking out that
bishop the pawn on d5
must continually be defended by this
knight on e7 so this
the knight on g5 could reroute itself to
the f4
square knight h3 knight f4 in time and
really pummel out your pawn
as the bishop lands on the diagonal as
well maybe bishop to
f3 white has to be careful you don't get
to play d4 too fast he's trying to get
b4
in to get some life as well so
definitely looking for play
but yermo has to giddy up i mean really
gideon here's g3
with the idea of push bishop to g2 is
what we were talking about
right now that
hmm my for can i
just like it before i i would play
i wouldn't investigate i just i mean
i mean this is getting a little
yeah this is getting a little bit wait a
minute wait a minute
this wasn't the clean pawn up
you know let me win a comfortable ending
that i was hoping for a moment ago
that one minute is alarming yes
on all the games guys and we have an
echo of last
game in that golden's game against joel
benjamin
still so few trades um
we did get to trade that light squared
bishop which was super useful because
the bishop on e6 was really cramping our
active play
but it it's another blitz game guys two
minutes to three minutes
with almost every piece and pawn still
on the board it's going to get wild
yeah oh no oh no something insane
happened in the game with
oh no wow he was trying to defend so
tenaciously
and he hung mate in one oh
the board first of all a6 he decided to
open up the diagonal after a6 with d5
why would you do that bishop e4 d6
rookie d8 there goes your pawn
93 b5 just flailing it looks like rook
takes ba6
and mate it's just uh blind spot
blind blind spot a number of a number of
poor moves
with plenty of time on the clock i mean
just he did not defend tenaciously
he did our first mate on the board guys
but will it be our last i don't think so
i don't think so
um by the way golden um i mean sorry uh
kaidana's game against dmitry girvich
not the most exciting game it is with
one of our co-leaders they got off to a
late start
so there's more time on that clock than
others so that's why we're not spending
as much time on it at the moment
it looks like an even game five five
versus five with all the majors on
exactly but we'll come back to that okay
joe benjamin super exciting shibala's
game
looked like it was about to blow up
after the move
b5 we were anticipating b4
rook b8 that was not the direction that
yerma went in he played d4 what a move
what a dramatic move in a situation like
this one
and he's not getting his pawn back
because the problem after night after
three is
right well at least one back is what i
mean yeah he's not getting back he's not
even getting one back because
this move knight f3 the rook can go to
h5 and attack
all the way across the rank and shabala
now simply up two pawns and saying do
you're saying you have
real compensation and it looks like alex
i should say yermo is flailing right now
trying to get a knight on d3
to argue the bishop doesn't really
belong on g2 after that last move
but you get the feeling this must be
lost yeah
rook h5 and rook takes b5 as you say
just coming across the board
looks like shibalov in the driver's seat
there joel benjamin's game
like his first round game looks like
it's coming to a blitz
uh finish as uh golden
is down what did you say two minutes one
minute to two minutes
golden's golden's golden superman
excuse me guys as
we had the same setup but then it was
shabbat who ended up losing on time
in this case joel's showing some lack of
form because two games in a row with no
time on the clock
yeah but now he just put his queen on g5
you would have thought that he would
want to put his queen on h6 so he could
play for
g5 and g4 uh
the queen on d3 was a little bit exposed
to the move e7 e5 golden dropped his
queen back
to the e2 square queen e2 and
joel he can't sit here for 30 seconds
like he's got 37 left
he's got 37. you bet he can't sit for
30. you've got to get theoretically he
could
but he ended up going under 30 seconds
he's at 26 and counting come on joe you
could play knight h5
in the new york uh instant here uh
h5 wow he spent nearly
two-thirds of his time on
h5 he's thinking too much it goes to
show
just what i was we were we were saying
about the time
control at the start of the broadcast 25
minutes and five seconds
is not a common time control for these
players when they play online they play
blitz chess
when they play in person they play
classical chess
so this is not a common time control and
knight e4
that looks like a very good move as
golden is about to play
e4 e5 to
cut this bishop takes
nightmare shabbat did win his game
knight b4 was actually made by knight to
e5
and guillermo said i don't i don't want
to bother myself with this position it's
two pawns
it's not enough compensation
surprisingly just
did he resign or did he lose on time
after this move because he was
at no he had 35 seconds left on his
clock
so he looks like he just said two puns
no
please uh enough respect for this guy
it's
it's too much two pounds just
satisfaction
84 okay so knight before um
obviously his idea like queen f3
kicked the knight back great if you play
queen f5
i was thinking uh you know me
uh give me a pawn
give me that pawn queen f3
king f3 knight g5 check
me that night guys we need a second we
need a second board
because patrick and larry are also in
the don brooke i mean this one
there's a rook put it on the analysis
board while we leave this one on the
left
we've got to pay both attention to both
at the same time the one on the right
is wolf versus christensen there's a
rook on e7 a queen on d1
is d3 actually hanging but the rook is
gonna
gobble everything on the seven i mean
these two positions are
wild with so little time left on the
clock and he played rook takes
d3 what a move with your king
looking like it it might die to some
kind of check
i know yet but the problem is the
desirable check and queen takes b7
keep in mind the knight is
uh attacking the rook and now you've got
to play rookie eight
and that trade of rooks is a big relief
for larry uh i think he was fearful of
his king simply getting checkmated
uh now with the bishop pinned he's much
better off look at alex golden only with
eight seconds
seven eight seconds six seconds eleven
for
for joel whoa knight d3
and and lane of sacrifice
he blundered the e5 pawn did uh
that uh alexander golden he had this
very nice pawn on e5 but joel just
took it thanks to him joel's not hiding
his emotions guys he looks happy right
now is he
he's f5 well he's like the cheshire
cat that just got the cream that wasn't
huge
and now he's lashing out e5 look at that
suddenly all of his pieces that were
imprisoned remember that
the bishop was on e6 the queen was on d7
we had no play
suddenly he has i'm sorry but joe
benjamin
is channeling walter brown right now
look at that i mean
look at walter brown alexander ivanov
these guys will get in
serious time pressure and start playing
genius
i look at him holding his heart joe joel
sitting there saying what am i doing to
myself i'm giving myself heart
palpitations
like 15 seconds with his opponent having
two minutes in both times
they go underneath him in time and joel
ends up the victor
with those strong nerves well
let's take a look at patrick wolf versus
christensen
i think larry has done very well
to get himself into a position where
uh his knight is the one defending his
king
and these knights are like you know
really wonderful
in terms of being able to do that now
having said that
you know he does have to worry about you
know
the queen is guarding the knight it's
not like the king is guarding the knight
because the king
can get driven away so uh larry is in a
i don't know a little bit of a pickle
maybe it's time to just step back with
the king
no he didn't feel he had to okay that
is a bold move i think bishop f6
is on uh patrick's agenda
king h3 played he didn't want to allow
queen d to check
so oh and larry larry's basically saying
i'm not
worried wow larry does not
think about like if he doesn't see mate
he doesn't care about you
and now he's he's a kid that's exposed
and here he comes check
do something with it check
and larry's if you go with your bishop
to
f6 okay i was about to say if you go
with your bishop to f6 larry had a check
on
d2 forcing the king to leave even though
it looked positive but
larry's just harassing that white king
and what happens if we step back king h3
now careful uh yeah i was about whoa
whoa whoa whoa
my spidey sense is tingling what's wrong
with grabbing upon jen
nothing said patrick i'll get i'll take
that pawn that will be
one well it does slightly expose the
king to light squared checks king g2 can
be made by queen e4
maybe he is
he is down he played g4 instead g4 even
more bald allowing knight f4 check
lowry didn't need to be told to play
that move kh4
look at that king the king
and larry said oh i have no more checks
okay
uh there was also the possibility of
queen h5 patrick said
okay now the king can make a
i was about to say the king could make a
rush
to the center because again queen h5
this
looks like larry's going down he's drunk
no i don't know these yes it's true but
boy nights can be tricky if somehow you
can get it over there unfortunately the
night is pinned
otherwise 97 would be very sweet
no the king has made it out of all of
the checking zone
and furthermore the king has turned into
an
enormous attacking people i know
absolutely absolutely
going after the queen what's this
that looks like a bluff it's some kind
of stalemate uh
hope there's no stalemate it's over
the queen is coming to h5 the knight is
hanging i think
larry is in he's run out of moves
he's run out of fuel for his checks he's
down
two pawns any queen trade now is dead
lost instantly
that one's over yeah and larry looks
like he's giving it a rest
and there patrick wolf a win and a loss
um he enters the tournament with a
tumultuous beginnings we have one game
left this game did get a late start guys
kaidana
um guys we've seen four wins so far
that's
four wins this round four wins this
round
this round am i mistaken patrick one
novakov one shabala of one benjamin won
that's right and this is going to be
possible draw most likely
as there's um a trade-off now
rook a5 rook b3 and
you know we've many times called draws
in positions and ended up blowing up but
guys this ain't going to be one of them
no this is not going to be one of them i
think it's pretty safe to say we're on
uh on on solid ground by saying that
this game is about to be
agreed drawn uh these two warriors
looking at each other saying
okay who's going to offer the draw who
knows how to draw on leeches
that's the point do you know how to
offer draw on leeches
we're about to find out but around we've
got plenty of time
four decisive games wow the mates
in one of them as well with the amazing
a lot of action in this one
well i was about to say i if i was in
larry's shoes i would feel very
disappointed with the outcome of this
game
i think he had a wonderful position
against patrick i think he was simply
better in fact
and then it was like patrick was the one
that was landing all the good
uh shots and larry was on the back foot
and it is finally he
dima seems to be taking they have agreed
no the drawer is done
the drawer is in the books okay i think
they have
a second electronic device that they can
talk
to chris bird the arbiter directly from
that's what
i think we just saw there with dima i
think he was trying to offer a draw
i agree yeah i think he wanted to make
sure that he was pressing the right
button to offer a draw and not
accidentally resigning
oops oops
yeah that could hurt that could hurt
well you know i feel like there's some
age itis in that one
jen you know ageism if you will no
because it was just because they looked
like they were looking around and
talking
that's why yeah and also if you have if
you don't play on leaches before there's
a couple confusing things about it
actually
i mean the pre-moves like everything's a
little different depends what your
dominant site is
but you know a lot of people um play on
wechat but a lot of people play on
chess.com so if you switch over to the
other one everything's a little
different
i'm teasing of course i was teasing
but we did have a round of amazing
fireworks pyrotechnics
four wins of course four losses you see
a lot of ones a lot of zeros
and joe benjamin
two insane time scrambles
that he's managed to emerge from
victorious to be sitting at the top
2-0 who's betting on joel to win it all
wow a lot of people hey you can't argue
with before
but i i think he's gotta you know shift
his strategy because
i don't know if he if anyone's nerves
certainly not his friends and family can
take it if he does that seven months
that uh i hate being a second to
time trouble addicts and joe getting
into time trouble back to back
no but his opponent lost on time both
games
right he did he did kind of confuse them
at some point because then
the problem is he's in the zone of
playing quickly and his opponent
isn't and suddenly they just uh
have this false sense of security and
lose on time to be fair he was way
better in both games when he ended up
winning on time right
exactly yeah at the finish yes at the
end
so he outplayed his opponent sometime
virtually which is something
in this in this time control that
deserves kudos
yeah so you say it all the time you
mentioned walter brown as one of those
time pressure addicts who turn into
monsters when
there's very few seconds left on the
clock joel has a little bit of that hit
in him as well victor courtney was also
not only a time trouble addict but when
he was in time trouble
he turned around games in the most
amazing way it was sort of like
people thought okay now that my opponent
is in time trouble
i'm going to play some good moves and
win on the clock they didn't realize
that that was their most vibrant state
that they were in and that walter brown
was
simply a great great blitz player he
could hustle you right
right out of any kind of position and uh
it seemed to me that uh well joel got a
little new york shuffle
of new york hustle there and uh brooklyn
joseph brooklyn in the house in the
house
and we're going to take a break and
we're going to see you on the other side
for the third and final round of today's
start of the senior championships
[Music]
what does it feel like playing for this
u.s title
online and what do you think some of the
challenges will be
it is going to be a big challenge for me
because i don't play online
at all i actually started some training
i
found well somebody was willing to play
me in a training match but
it is going kind of rough for me i don't
know it's just
it's weird well it's it's of course it's
unfortunate that we all have to
now play uh online but that's fantastic
that they
that you guys are organizing the same
the same
event the same price fund because now
this was
all open open tournaments uh online they
run with reduced prices like five ten
times
so you guys just keep the prices that's
fantastic
absolutely shocking that uh first of all
we have to do this
okay uh we kind of accepted that there's
gonna be no tournament this year so uh
kudos to saint louis chess club that's
uh
fantastic on their part uh yeah i'm very
happy to be invited you know i
i'm very happy the tournament this they
actually want to hold it you know
you know i understand that this
tournaments are online for me it's not
easy because i am
an old old-fashioned an old guy i'm the
second oldest in tom
tournament and it's kind of technical
difficulties for me
it's very strange and i i have not been
playing
online uh during this uh covert time
uh i don't particularly like playing
online
in normal times i don't do a lot of
practice online
it feels very weird that we have to have
so many precautions
to you know make sure that everything is
on the level
i don't think for a millisecond that
anybody in this tournament would
cheat anyway but it's gonna just gonna
be
just going to be weird you know your
concerns are split between
playing a good game and making sure that
you don't commit a technical violation
oh weird
yeah so um so i'm excited
i'm i'm really really excited because
the break was
was for so long and
uh despite the fact that the uh
time control is not ideal it's much
better than
blitz which i'm already you know fed up
with
i don't know it's going to be different
i mean i haven't played a serious game
of chess in a very long time
i'm just hoping i don't embarrass myself
i'm looking forward to the to the
challenge of it
but the fact that it's online basically
makes it possible for me to play
this there's no way i i could not have
taken like two weeks out to fly to st
louis and you know play one game a day
and so on and so forth
um but when i saw that was online and i
could do it from home in three days i
thought
all right i'll i'll take the time see if
i can get myself in some sort of shape
and
and play so i'm excited about it i don't
i don't know
i have never played online actually and
i don't know
how it will go i have no idea
uh it'll be a challenge um
technically and you know you have to be
careful about where you put your eyes
and all that stuff
but i'm used to i'm used to playing
online but it will be
i'll try to do some practice games i'll
i'll be i'll be ready
it's definitely a privilege i never
would have
expected the opportunity to emerge
especially looking at the field of the
golden players
who uh players who used to dominate uh
us chess from three four decades ago
i'm preparing and looking forward this
is the best thing chest wise
which would happen to me you know in a
long time
[Music]
we are back at the 2020 u.s senior
championship
with a clear leader two victories two
time scrambles two flags fallen
as grandmaster joel benjamin he's at the
top with two points
gregory kaidana vinnie goranovica with
one and a half points from two games
and shavula and wolf both bouncing back
from round one losses and dimitri
girvich is playing a
solid tournament at 50 beautiful
sentiments being expressed there
uh by the players in those interviews
maurice i really got the
the sense that the players are very very
pleased with the tournament very
grateful to the saint louis chess club
and the sink fields and anxious to do
battle
yes indeed and that's such a good point
the fact that
all these events are being honored in
such a wonderful way as we see
the pairings there some critical
pairings certainly going into the next
round joel benjamin
with two points at the top playing
against gregory cardone off who started
off well
at one and a half that's got to be the
key battle of the round
you'll see some other good matchups as
well but
it's so important to honor the country's
national championships
and to have five of them this month as
jen said earlier the
championship october have five of them
in one month
extraordinary and every one of them just
getting better and better as we go along
and this one the players are indeed
honored to be able to still
represent their country and battle
for their country's title and know that
they're
they're being watched they're
commentated on they're going to be paid
for it
as well despite the fact that they're on
the tail end the twilight years and
their careers
although i mean 50 is pretty young for a
senior
but i love it i think it's a great i
think it's a great break breaking point
for
the age limit even though of course
technically
legally it's not really a senior and
many 50 year olds are in fantastic shape
but it's great for chess because chess
is
becoming such a young person's game that
they are
you know unlikely to get an invite into
the main event unless they win the us
open right
right so i think it's a fantastic event
that
is so interesting and i'm glad that it's
a 50 plus they do the same thing in
poker
at some point they also added like a
super seniors event that was 65 plus for
like
the legally defined seniors yeah i think
they even have something like a 75 year
old
age age
championship in chess as well and by the
way big
shout out to our senior players
i believe they are the gold medalist
uh back-to-back olympic gold medalist
for seniors
um for the last two cycles so
our seniors are pretty good seniors are
better than anyone else's scene
yeah our seniors are better than your
seniors so take that
aging well and aging well
there's no one who's technically 65 plus
they're all
in between the ages of 52 and 64.
right yeah pretty pretty uh interesting
there
although i think a lot of these guys as
they get a couple years older
will still be invited to this event so
that's average is bound to change but
it's that time in the show guys
predictions
i'll let you guys go first whoa okay
maurice uh go for it first you always
complain that you're the last
this will be the first time in broadcast
history
i've been allowed i've been allowed the
first before
long long long long time ago
you know i see that big fat too at the
top
and he is from brooklyn on top of it
what can you say
um but you know what i'm gonna go with
shabba ranks
shabala he did it last year i'm
seeing him coming back from that early
loss
and adding up some points so not maybe
the easiest pick after two rounds
but i'm gonna go with that your pick
uh i was the boy you really you really
took me
back there because i was sure you were
going to
go with joel you know fraternity
brotherhood everything
but no i'm going to go
with gregory kaidanoff all right great
pick
feel good pig i'm going to take joel
benjamin
because hey his nerves are showing
formidable when it counts and so far so
good
and bar takes travel of also agreeing
with maurice so
wow unique picks from the team
and we are off for the third final game
critical game yes joel benjamin versus
gregory
kaidanov and we've got
aaron lopez on tap yeah the old morphe
line not the uh
berlinda berlin defense but a7a6
by the way notice that joel again we've
re we
we mentioned the fact that he's written
books about the openings he
played knight f3 in one game is white
and now has opened up with one e2 e4
in another game so mixing up his
openings
and we have an open rui
on the board something that uh gregory
kaidanov has actually played throughout
his career
and this will not have come as a
surprise to joel so we'll see what
the players have prepared for each other
and as we came on
the show uh i had asked you jan
about the drawing of lots and you
explained to me that the players did
their drawing at the opening ceremony
which was a week or so ago and so they
knew
the colors that they would play against
one another and we know that gregory
loves this line
um so definitely joel's prepared and i
think that's
really important because you know
gregory is a very practical player he
would be a bad person to use the same
technique that joel used in the first
three games um yeah
he's just so um disciplined gregory and
so
um practical right that exactly and i
think joel knows that
you could see his body language after
that last game he was like
i'm not going to do that to myself again
yeah he seemed to be clutching his heart
like oh boy this was the big one queen
v6
and i must say that uh as both players
have been playing very quickly
i i'm i'm quite certain that uh they are
still
in the depths of theory and i would even
go far as to say that there's probably
at least a thousand games in the
database
from this very very specific position
black has just played the move queen b6
inviting an end game let's go around a
thousand games yeah can i ask you yes
before we move on since this is
such a critical game first of all i'm
assuming that the pawn
on d5 is taboo because our knight on b1
isn't protected yet
so we're going to run into some some
problems with uh
work to d8 and if
yeah immediately or now
it just all looks really dangerous okay
so
the pawn is not it's upon that not even
yasser loves
yeah yeah and man i love my pawns a
little bit taboo for the time being
oh by the way we did see a queen tray
that was going to be my second question
if
we could um keep queens on the board but
um
no that wasn't the case knight a3 and
now bishop takes d5 is a real threat
right exactly
and the other nice thing i really like
about that because a moment ago you just
said well
knight's not developed uh if you look at
the position you say well what's the
square
that my knight on b1 should go to you
would say oh i'd like it on the d4
square please
trade nights and then i get to play f3
and f4 and the knight on
d4 will be blockading the the
the past d5 pawn so knight a3 instant
move by
joel as he's looking to reroute the
knight and like you say
now there is a pawn on
d5 that could be vulnerable so uh
again i suspect uh you remember issue
we're about to say maybe a thousand that
was
over guesstimating it seemed like a lot
of
a lot of moves a lot of game skills
position
until you start to think about the open
spanish
and how many years decades decades
decade
centuries centuries centuries oh yeah
have they been playing
open space spanish right certainly was
just
talking about this particular line
itself the queen e2 rook d1 variation i
don't know believe which is called the
warrell attack
i believe attack
i think that's what it's called but
maybe it's not the variation but queen
e2 certainly not
the most popular way to play with c4 i
remember paul carey's
playing this back in the day
before i was born of course but
classical
classic games from cary's with this idea
of c4
and it's positional
right now for bl for white white is
trying to get something blockading the
square d4
knight on a3 right now headed to c2 to
d4
and seeing what can happen there i don't
know one weakness for black
maybe a weakness for white as well and
he's five and you know the nice thing
about joel benjamin is you can really
feel his joy of winning those first two
games i know you're not supposed to like
carry the emotions from the games before
but hey in times like this
if you've got happiness ride with it
right
you know it's fun to win two games in a
row in an elite competition
why not enjoy enjoy the feeling exactly
and by the way i saw for me in the
interview that you were having maurice
and this time with uh shabby chabaloff
he was like almost expressing his
frustration like
it's unthinkable that this has been
going on so long
you know but it's like okay but at least
we get to play chess no no
now we can do something these next three
days so i really got a feeling
like uh these guys are really happy for
a break
from their routines yeah you just spoke
about shabbat
could we please look at his position
surely because
you can always expect or at least
most of the time expect there's going to
be some fire on that chessboard
and look at this he stacked upon in the
opening with the move
b5 after queen to d2 and
i mean he just did it a tempo like
bing let's go if you could go to this
position on
move eight after queen to d2
yeah ted samish sacrifice
b5 give me give me and
novikov said i'm taking it e5 to follow
d5 to keep it going capture with the
knight
your king's still stuck in the middle of
the board but it could be two connected
passers after knight takes
and it has occurred this is some
exciting theory here
now i play the same ash and i'm familiar
with the idea
of b5 that uh benko gambit
uh as you said at uh queen d2 but i'm
really familiar
with the move c5 first like this is a
prelude that they always play they
always include c5
nobody has ever just flat out played the
move b5 against me
and igor said well isn't it a pawn
and now he's arguing that well he's got
two connected pass pawns over there
you whatever it is that black's got to
do you better do it quickly because
bishop e2
in castles is game over so you could
still you could still a couple of moves
though i mean you still
have to play bishop too and capsules and
by the way you lowered the boom
could we look at i'm looking at the
computer bar
and it's saying black down the pawn
has not only compensation but might be
slightly
better even wow okay we've got to
should tell me the computer's moves
maurice because i'm not looking at the
moves i'm just oh i'm sorry
okay uh i mean i i understand that queen
h4
check g3 queen like if you play rook e8
right and i play bishop e2 just
choosing some moves i can understand
that your queen
harassing me could keep my king in the
center
longer than i want it to be there but
i could also meet the
queen h4 check with king f1
getting ready like at the moment i just
kind of messed up my rook i understand
that
but at least your queen isn't harassing
me on h3
um i'm not sure i see the full
compensation
uh that the computer does and
alex doesn't either because he would
have moved already
he's now looking for moves so clearly
he's out of his
his prep and now he's looking for a move
after this knight c3 what's that
it's not a2 it's not b2 i'm really
looking i don't like those pawns
even being on the board two connected
passers
as you said if he just gets his bishop
into the game and counts game over
you're done you need a move you need to
add something
add some spice but f5 doesn't doesn't
work at all
no that just looks like a step in the
wrong direction
i'm looking at rookie eight i can
imagine
queen a5 as being some kind of
ghost-like moves
i can imagine queen h4 so let's one more
look
rookie eight bishop e2 so
now you got to do this
there's just no choice right you've got
to
harass me but this time i'll play bishop
f2
and again i don't see it as soon as i
castle what do you door is shut
what do you do about bishop basics i'm
just throwing it out there rookie a
bishop rookie a yes richard
okay now that yeah because
the desirable bishop a6 you can take
and now you're
you read my mind right so i
will have to castle if i can
but if you castle now i want to take on
e2
right and you got
you got me which means that i have to do
something even less desirable
i have to keep e2 defense now you got me
excited wow
oh now you have a2 now you have a2
which is at least
oh i'm happy with this yeah this is what
i'm getting out of this position i'm
thrilled yeah i think that that's right
maurice you should be thrilled takes
queen
queen check and i don't even get to
drive your rook
back uh from a2 very good okay so
that that has to be it uh rookie a
bishop e2 bishop a6 okay
let me try this one takes on
e5 okay
in this case i'm gonna take on e2 i
again want to take on e2
so if you take with the rook
i suppose i wanted to play rook takes
what i i suppose i wanted to play rook
takes because
i'm a little bit concerned my
bishop pinned along the e-file is an
issue
but can i just take on d5 and take on a2
and hit your b2
pawn before you castle yes yeah it looks
good
yeah i also have queen a5 check this was
the
queen a5 you have queen d2 at least but
even that i could trade queens and hit i
mean it's
hmm no i take one but i i think i think
rook takes a2
is good enough for equality no no
no castles rook takes b2
c4 good enough for equality hmm how
about that so
but it does take a very precise
order of moves by by shabalov here
rookie rookie ate one more look let's
say i take
now this one oh i am definitely
um a little frisky yes
yes that's exactly right i i'm
definitely
being frisky he has played
where would my knight my knight needs to
be on c4
i also want to play d4
you know doesn't quite get there yet
and
a pawn on a2 is really an achilles
achilles heel i mean darn it every time
i play knight takes d5 or do something
like knight takes e2 that rook
lands on a2 and i'm an
unhappy camper if i play bishop takes e5
here
in your line you play bishop e2
e5 no i'm i'm really
worried that a queen is about to land
against me with check if i play the
desirable knight d5
i keep running into rook oh yes
yucky yucky yucky do okay and if i play
king f2 oh i'm not even going to
calculate
i'm saying good just say happiness i'm
just happy that it happens
i've got to have compensation in this
position so i mean for starters queen h4
check is funny and i dropped back okay
d3 would have been mapped by bishop g3
exactly
that was that gen g3 right
and now that i'm happy by the way giving
you my dark square bishop but
i'm wondering can i trap your queen down
here it looks
it looks dangerous it does look
dangerous but i'm not sure it's trapped
right queen is like forced and now i go
to f5
i think this is compensation for white
yeah definitely right
uh but i i play king
g1 a la tempo because i was thinking
that you know what i'll put my bishop
back on
f2 i'll be as snug as a bug i'll play h4
h5 and develop my rook unnaturally
but i will develop my rook how how about
this how about that
really asking for it that's what it is
but it was actually my style throughout
my whole career
really i was provocative and anybody who
wants to look at some crazy
games look at my games with shabbat
shabbat i i
really he told me that you know i i
i put him off his tournament because i
would be like
waving a red flag and he would go red
flag attack
i waited some more and then he'd go
flying off a cliff
that's what you're doing to me right now
because i'm like are you
crazy but i can't find a way
in i want to play d4 uh my sock and
exchange somehow
i once played a grand master from poland
prison of poker not krasnopulski uh
it was in istanbul under the olympiad
and krasenkov unfortunately at the time
his english wasn't so
good so he was speaking to me in russian
and shibala of shabba was doing the
translating because shabba is my
teammate obviously
and uh it was like
two weeks later shabbalah came up to me
and said kris zenkov has
told him that since our game he hasn't
he hasn't been regular
it just ruined his olympiad and
moves like king f2 to g1 the
car me maneuvers i wanted to say like
king e 1 to f2 to g1 work part and
parcel of my
play i i oftentimes made king walks
and my opponent electric
electrocution at the board uh
how alex just poured himself some more
coffee is he gonna need it for this
position
yeah he may very very well made uh let's
go
and jump in and see the game of uh
dimitri and patrick wolf that's
much much much more tame looks like in
english and okay we'll have to wait
for this game to unfold white is looking
to play
b4 and h3 into for some resolution
of the position okay meanwhile in the
game with
all the points we've got with all the
points yeah we got our perfect score
and gregory kaidana after knight a3
uh rook d8 knight c2 knight a5
now the 95 like you could take on b3
which gregory
did but you know knight c4 was another
potential idea with that move so
joel is trying to hit back and post up
on
d4 c6 as we see happen
right now one of the things that what
black
tends to do in his from black's
perspective
is black says okay i doubled up your
pawns
even if you end up winning this pawn one
day
and it'll take you hard work to get
there
i'll have this great compensation
because i'll always have
a pawn to attack so knight takes b3 and
the we've are we caught up with the
players i think we
are and you know i will just say
that in my view we're still in gregory
kaidanov's prep
like gregory uh really really worked
hard on his openings and he looked
very very deeply even
you know into some middle game and late
end game positions and i would say that
i would be surprised if gregory didn't
have this on his
homework table because all of the play
has been very natural from both sides
yeah that's right and you can see a
potential of a lot of trades in this
game
so um high chances that it would be a
well-played draw in my opinion b4 just
played
and that potentially opens up more
trades
exactly you know what do you do here
probably
move your knight if you take or take
probably i i was thinking that uh
gregory is probably going to just simply
move his knight
and not take e6 what happens with takes
i'm thinking rook takes so that i draw
the rook away from
its attack on the e5 pawn
and knight takes so that
d5 is a little bit tender and that f3
move now comes in handy because if i try
something like knight 96 which would
normally work beautifully
i'm trying to compel you to take now
knight d5 you can just
take back with the rook and you've got
that not worried
i worry about that yeah i don't have to
worry about the
back ranked mates anymore because like
you said i i have made luft
and b before i think before it would be
favorable for white so
instead you're suggesting just knight e6
immediately
yeah with the idea that you don't have
time to take a free pawn
on a5 because knight f4 is going to
distract
your knight away because you can't take
with the rook because of bishop c6
exactly exactly exactly all also true
and we would get some position like this
where well maybe this is weak
but maybe this guy is weak as well
but no by the way he took on v4 okay
and i'm wondering if after you know what
your idea of
rook a rook a8 knight before does that
mean he's compelled to play bishop e6
to protect the pawn i don't see another
way to protect him unless there's a
a rook a4 type move but no i just take
on d5
right yeah
that's not that horrible right it's just
a little it's not it's not horrible but
it feels like a concession of sorts
that white has won some control
over the position that he's forced your
bishop to take up
a a a passive role
of just being a defender now having said
that it's
not necessarily terrible or anything but
i would have thought that gregory would
want something more and joel
joel seems to be interested in the
position by the way joel using a lot
more time
than gregory to get here 20 minutes to
12 minutes
let's keep an eye on this game as we go
to irmo
and alexander golden this looks
also like the players are in theory
although i must say
white sure looks to have
his pieces on effective squares
like look at all of this is good this is
good this is
great this is good this is okay
maybe it would be better here whereas
look
look look three rather awkward looking
pieces so
i'm thinking yermo did some excuse me
that was just a
me trying to clear my arrows your mo
did something good or golden did
something bad
and the time the clocks are telling me
that golden did something bad
because this just looks good for white
no
ifs ands or buts about it by the way in
the position that
we were looking at with shabbat novakov
after some thought
jabalov had played rook to e8 novakov
played king to f2
you're king march immediately though not
with taking on e5
avoiding bringing us a strong piece to
e5 possibly
and king f2 on the board
and i've i'd be in that camp the the
krasenkov camp i'd be
here electrocuted
yeah hang up in my face gotta find a
move here and shabala of
sinking into thought as you know the
creativity of this man is extraordinary
he's the reigning champ here and he is
looking
look you see there he just pulled his
his shirt up over his mouth
uh up to his nose the top of the shirt
anyway
and he's thinking his eyes are just
darting around
how do i hurt this guy right
a lot in poker because people the neck
pulsates when you're showing emotions so
kind of their neck and like cover their
um their mouth as well
but yeah hey by the way if navakov does
get away with this and somehow wins the
game we should point out
he'll likely be tied for the lead going
in today too
because i'm getting one and a half point
now that puts him in a tie for second
so i mean that depends on joel's result
but we do think that
you know even if maybe after this night
before idea he has the edge
um you know obviously there's a lot of
trades in that game
so there's some chances it'll come back
even if joel was to
clip upon exactly let's just jump to the
game of larry
versus shelby obviously shelby's walking
around
with the uh target
on his back but larry just lost
his game to patrick wolfe can he get
back to the winners column
in this game we just saw let's see we've
seen some trades there was an
on passant it looks like and larry
is not in attacking mode so much as he's
got
some pressure against the backward pawn
on d6
and sometimes that's what you got to do
is you just got to keep
the pressure on your opponent and get
them to uh play defensive chess
and uh well okay larry
has an edge we'll leave it there for now
let's just go back to our points game
as you said jen and interestingly enough
a joel did not trade rooks he just
recaptured offering
is e5 pawn as bait yeah i think so
because i think he's just calculating
that he's going to win more pawns in his
opponent rook a1 rook a1
rookie rookie 5 rook a8 shaq
and now if you play bishop e8 i can play
knight takes d5
right yep and then i have an active rook
and i clipped the pawn and now here
after knight d5
um we're even in pawns momentarily but
how are you going to defend v6 you're
going to have to get really passive to
do it and
and 97 allows knight c7
potentially which i don't know if that's
very good or not
but just just a point about how
passive your pieces are that i kind of
have my pick of what to trade here if i
want to
is this enough for white though it
doesn't feel
doesn't i i i i'm not shaking in my
boots let's put it that way
now the thing is is you you didn't have
to
necessarily trade rooks you could have
started
with the move knight takes d5 gen and
then i'm kind of feeling a little bit
more um unhappy
i want to say as black because here
i don't have the defensive move knight
d7
right so rook d5 still fails to rock a8
oops
yep so i would have to go
after a knight that's why i'm thinking
knight d5 maybe joel
uh is for choice here
now what do we do here um you're
threatening my pawn on b6
and i don't have knight d7 as you point
out
and now something like b5 now the idea
of rook jack
and knight c7 starts to become very
attractive so
maybe this is uh yeah joel's entire
entire point and you know we're back to
playing the move we
didn't necessarily want to play for
gregory bishop
e6 the the
the counterpoint to bishop e6 is it it
does make knight d7
possible and maybe bishop e6 i have to
go with
that passive move yeah but advantage for
white
will it be enough lots of material is
going to get traded but
absolutely goal on top um in terms of uh
pushing
so what do we what do we got here you're
looking you're moving us to uh garvich's
game against
yeah because it looked like dimitri
there's his uh pawn that got extended
pawn went all the way to a4 and dimitri
said
let me take that pawn and patrick said
okay
i'm a pawn down but look what i've got
i've got a great bishop on g7
protecting an excellent knight on d4
uh this pawn on f4 means that maybe
maybe on a good day i can play queen h4
rook to g5 and play a dark square attack
on the king side i would say
good compensation good compensation is
in
i would prefer to play black it's easier
to play
black this extra pawn on a3 is not going
anywhere
anytime soon so i see uh
queen h4 rook g5 and i think that that
patrick will be pleased
with this position i was going to tease
you
what's that tease you and say hey take a
look at this position where
a free pawn for watching you
and you made a fool out of me and said i
i like blind
i i understand i got my hand caught in a
lot
of cookie jars i mean a lot
and this looks like one of those cookie
jar positions where
you can just see you can see a lot of
easy moves for black if you
if you imagine the queen coming to h4
not easy to boot that queen out
the rook sliding across so that you can
threaten
h3 and you start to feel the heat again
the extra pawn is over here
and that's not where the action is the
action is on the king side
advantage patrick speaking of action
yes big development in the game between
novakov
and shabbalov a critical moment as
king f2 e takes d4 by shabala
it's not one of those things you want to
do bring by making exchanges
you always want to know what happens
after the exchange occurs on the board
and this exchange
brings white's bishop to a centralized
square more centralized square
than on e3 you'd prefer that the capture
happened on e5 where
your knight would take back on e5 and
it be centralized by the capture from
your opponent
instead he's captured brought the bishop
and then he played knight e5
so two moves to get a position that he
could have gotten in one if white
had obliged and then he
after 95 the move bishop to b5
lands on the board and it's clear white
just wants to swing the rook to e1
get the king tucked back on g1
and say did i steal a pawn
yes you did do you have compensation
right now
and the passive bishop to d7 just
seemingly giving
white a free move um
that's i don't like the last two moves
for black i don't like the way that went
anyway and white now trading the bishop
off
and it looks like he's just going to get
in and rook to e1
and what what does he have he should
probably
be in big trouble right now and
i mean that's that's the point of the
dynamic advantage versus the static
advantage of uh
material uh pawn uh the static advantage
doesn't leave the board dynamic
advantage is
you know dissipate and yeah and i
like to move rookie 8 a lot and i like
what
what happened here that king f2 was
provoked
but this trade marisa
i feel that played into white's hands
and that shibalov didn't
make the most out of his position now
having said all of that i'm not exactly
sure
what uh suggestion i might have had
right go ahead right yeah like like
let's see
yeah like e5 e4 might have been a move
that
i would have found attractive like
trying to open up
and expose the white uh king a little
bit like if you play move like
this then i can come over here and play
for g5 and
and f5 uh but
you're right when you when you look at
helping white post up his bishop
and this bishop is actually awesome
right it kind of
like radiates in all the directions you
start to realize
hey man that bishop is really strong by
the way it blockades a pawn
and after 95 bishop it looks to me like
my gosh igor is just like cruising he's
he's got a really good position you
can't even play knight c4 here
because if you do something like this
this could be hurtful
ouch right but that's a good point you
made knight c4
is a possibility so if queen takes now
which i'm surprised he's sitting
for so long thinking about it if queen
takes what did you have against
he has played knight c4 and look at the
computer bar go
absolutely nuts what very
risky move on his part and now his eyes
are wide
as saucers as well shabbat i mean
you make a move like that one you should
be shocked by your own move
i think you missed queen f4 i really do
because once you see queen f4 you go
oh my goodness like that does everything
that keeps
contact with the bishop uh
it you know has an x-ray attack against
this knight
on c4 by the way i'm a piece up and the
rook is hanging
you know oh man
the um the moves already been played
guys queen f4 on the board
that's such a harmonious move why not
yeah it looks great
it's such a harmonious move shabala's
last three moves
it just the the fingertips you know
the the sacrificial elan
that and panache i'm looking for the
right word am i saying good words
just throwing out french words there
they're very nice can help you with a
little latin if you like
carpe diem
well that's german the skill set the the
the the feel that shabbalah off i'm
going to do like a basic english word
the field that shabbat normally shows
when he sacrifices material
those last few moves didn't feel right
just didn't seem like he nailed it
he brought a bishop to the middle he let
the bishop go to b5 then he just plainly
offered a trade
then he played this with knight c4 and
forced the queen onto this power square
f4
and white's pieces are just blossoming
on every single move
and i think shabbat was in trouble
absolutely
in this position things are not looking
good for me and var's
pick uh right now as novikov no one
picked him
but he could be jumping to two and a
half after this game as his
position just looks fabulous right now
yeah absolutely
but you know you never count shabba love
off you know the problem with shabba in
this format guys as i said it before
you would think that this type of
swashbuckling style is good for rapping
and blitz but it's actually exhausting
you know he's played his third
ridiculously crazy game in a row right
whereas
exactly normally most of the other
players are going to have like one or
two games like this in the tournament
and one of them is going to be against
chabazov himself
the problem with him the problem with
him is that he's up and down as well
he can either do great or we've seen him
just crash and burn
he has that tendency but that's why he
has four titles i mean it's better in a
way
wouldn't you rather have four titles and
four horrible results than
you know zero titles but a lot of second
and third places right
six seconds no no no no give me but yeah
so you have four titles
right i don't see you i did up and down
player no
no no i did it just you know the calm
methodical
you know give me your pawns baby you
know uh
i just wanted to say yes you were always
higher you were higher rated i mean you
were one of the top
you know three players in the world at
some point no i was
i was top ten you were talking about
number nine yeah but uh
i mean it is a favorite so four titles
was like actually not
that many for you right no uh
unfortunately rexingfield wasn't around
when i was playing in the u.s
championships and
our u.s championships really had well
like 60 000
in prizes they were like 16
players in the tournament 16 players
and the top eight got a prize and the
bottom eight
got what was called point money so you
got a hundred bucks for every point that
you got
and these tournaments lasted three weeks
and it was sort of like you know oh
three weeks uh you know
you really had to sacrifice a lot so a
lot of the us championships
weren't attractive tournaments for me
and i had to decline
a lot of my invitations to u.s
championships in favor of other events
today the us you got players coming from
all over the world
wanting to get into our u.s championship
events uh so it's it's a completely
different
moment of time and these u.s
championships are are
generously funded by the saint louis
chess club so big thank you to
uh to uh the club but it is transforming
our championships yeah may i say
this begin this business of theoretical
preparation
up to move 13 14 even
shabbat love had blitzed out his moves
just right
right drop drop he had whipped out
on d5 he took knight takes d5 i mean all
this was
instantaneous a tempo take takes and it
was after knight to c3 that he stopped
for a moment
and so he looked like he was out of his
prep he finally played rook to e8
and then king f2 rookie here was a nice
move we like but king f2
he takes d4 bringing the bishop into the
game we didn't like that movie we didn't
like that one okay 95 we understand
[Music]
not a big fan of knight e5 either okay
but then bishop d7
was that his only move probably at that
point
but bishop a6 is another idea if you
take the rook was a knight d3
check tactic that was possible could
have been
interesting but he played bishop's d7
more passive not really shabala of like
if you will
and then he lashed out with knight to c4
and queen of four on the board
and so after all that prep half his
moves at least
have been moves that we say um we don't
like the way you follow this up
no and he's in a disastrous situation
his clock ticking down now he is only
344
and counting it's just he's put himself
in a precipitous situation incredible
how you can prepare and a couple of
moves later
out of your prep and not showing that
great form
that delicate aggressive form that we're
used to seeing with chavalo and his
now he looks lost yeah and there are
players
that need to play lots and lots of games
like 100 150
tournament games a year to feel in shape
and for me shibalov has always been one
of those
players that love to play they're just
all over the map they go from tournament
to tournament
and they're used to playing a long
sequence a long series of tournaments in
a row
shabbat just i mean he he has not this
entire year
he's probably been stuck in doors just
like everybody else very good
so i mean he's not and look at what
look at this move though from the mind
what on earth now g5 goes to show that
he did forget
about the knight hanging on c4
doubtlessly
he was ready to play this position
maybe not until he realized row
that was a winner as the pin on the
default so
he's had to do something that is let's
face it guys
uh a prayer and a hope um
hoping that the queen goes to like a
square where the knight can attack it on
e3
like queen f5 so that after bishop d4
rook d4 knight e3 you won't have time to
um take my rook on e8 at least this is
just a mad
madness but yeah that's that's
i think that's probably what he's got to
do he's trying to mix it up
yeah where can the queen go that's a
safe square where
let's see so you don't have to worry
about all that jazz a square where you
can't play knight e3 at the end of the
line
so for instance g3 or c1
c1 looks remarkable see one actually
looks i love moves like queen c1
retreating moves keep your eye on the g5
pawn
ouch actually what do you do yeah and if
you take
take queen f6 first of all i have not
recaptured this bishop this pawn is
hanging with check
yeah this looks terrible this looks
completely busto what a great move
queen c1 that looks beautiful i'm going
to say i love retrieve reading moves
at least that's my aesthetic preference
is to see a retreating move
like queen c1 i mean queen g3 also
probably doesn't i i
was about to say unfortunately for shab
for
for shambhala if uh queen g3 looks
really good too
the whole point is if you yeah you're
right you don't lose a piece but
yuck i mean yuck
and he did play queen c1 though he
played queen c1
keeping the eye on that rook on e8
and the the pawn on g5
i mean exactly what can you say there's
so many threats
and something like this is
really really curtains too right looks
terrible let's leave
in his own predicament uh
larry looks okay
uh hasn't broken through uh shelby is
hanging in there
um sorry what about your mo
when we
very very good nice pawn on v5
yeah it's a beauty and uh bishop f4 and
means that the pawn on d5 is going to
advance to d6
this looks like a very good position for
your mo
back to joel benjamin holy smokes it
looks like the cleaning
the the cleaners arrived and then it
kind of arrived in a variation that
well i'm surprised that joel played rook
check because we were looking at yeah
we preferred knight d5 it looked like it
had more spice
rook jack and gregory got in that move
knight d7 and that was the
key defensive move and
well this looks very balanced i i don't
see a problem here
unless i'm overlooking something
isn't it time to uh no that looks
let's not stick on this one we have five
seconds to look at stuff
the move the game you want to go to is
gurovich wolf and the g5 move was played
by
black black's last move was g5 we saw
shabala do it under
suspicious circumstances but here
this move after queenie won g5 and black
is on the hunt
the dark square domination just looks
wonderful
knight he's hoping to get him off his
back with
just trying to trade pieces off but
isn't g4 coming with
force at some point and that just looks
tremendous
yeah that looks nasty it looks like i'm
forced to capture
do i have a choice and after
bishop takes well
you can end up even taking this pawn i'm
afraid
some move like rook g5 but if you wanted
to play bishop takes f2
that oh we have a d oh we have something
completely different on the board now
this is a real song
the rook on the a5 is hanging right so
that's oh
thank you okay
oh the the rook on a5 is hanging
that he has taken by the way did patrick
on f3 oh there i think he played g4 and
the work on a5 is still
hanging but you're getting you look like
you're getting mated if you know let's
see how i get mated
pawn takes and now okay
is this truly mate maybe it is we had a
look yeah well i do
not like though right or queen h1 yeah i
do
i'm still in there with a shout out all
right let's try again
is there any is there anything okay
let's try again let's try again
okay so from the starting position we
took a rug
you took my pawn we all agree about that
or do we got to take on h3
one okay we have to take on h3 yeah okay
now we can play bishop
bishop v5 would be so deep that's
amazing that's great like
right now that looks beautiful
you you get the queen away from g5 and
you stop the knight from taking on f4
precisely i mean i want to say that's
kind of unbelievable
because yeah we cut both crucial
defenses
queen f5 as well as knight f4 and we say
deal with
this deal with that beautiful
funny move um yes yeah nice right
and uh maybe it means that in this
particu
particular position don't don't touch
the rook good luck with your position if
you don't even win material
well wait a minute do i have brooks
headed to g5
so you can't take that rock and you know
you're you're you're just gonna be a big
big
wait but what did you wrote a book with
uh
with uh my old trainer nikolai minov
take my rooks you know that was the
double rook sacrifice
and nikolai had some amazing
finds of double rook sacrifice so he
took on
g4 i like this decision because i think
bishop e5 was a winner
and what about the same type of line
though pawn takes g4
and if queen eight and the rook is
headed
headed to h5 in this line so it hit
more possibilities for the rook and now
you're saying move um because again f3
and knight f4 has been annoying
so let's play your move again um is
there f here
that was my question is there f3 here
and the answer is likely no but
go ahead and kill me well let's see
because punch
well g3 what's wrong with you if you
take i was thinking that maybe i can do
some resistance
like this right okay but okay okay
let's try yeah of course
a whole rook what's a rook amongst
friends i mean come on
cool i mean oh bishop d4
i was about to play knight takes
expecting that i i could defend
magnificent
no sir bishop d4 check is on your agenda
g3 looks like a winner work f2 yeah
you have to play rook f2 and pray that
you get out of this alive at some point
which is probably his best defense
actually
right now demetri is really thinking
things over because right here
crazily enough he hasn't
no he can't play no he can't play f3
there's just simply queen h3 and with hi
you gotta take the rock down
i gotta take the rook now now i have no
choice
and we've been looking at this and this
he's got one minute left on his clock 59
seconds to defend this
oh patrick wolf four minutes but the
position looks great
maurice yeah patrick won his last game
and is now
looking to go two in a row and the rook
has been captured
but this attack looks ferocious
just take and bring the bishop on e5 you
know you have what is more than enough
compensation
for this attack and he's going to be
proud of this game patrick
he sacked a pawn in the opening along
knight takes a4
and then played this idea of just dark
square attack
then played g5 g4 guys this is
this is like a classical game it really
is right i mean
this is what you'd be proud of if you
played in classical chess
no question about it now go ahead and
kill me guys
f3 g3 i'm assuming g3
forward look after i mean look after his
force
i would i would check you on h4 i don't
want to see you running
on h4 i just don't want to see you
running
okay now now here we go you want to play
rook h1 my rook wants to get to the g
file oh so so king h7
novocop did win and he's now in the lead
with two and a half out of three
joel of course trying um likely to join
him if this game against kaidanov is
indeed drawn although joel is down to
42nd
so well let's just switch this looks
like patrick has
this game i really love the emerging age
seven
followed by rook g8 joe benjamin
and um gregory are in
a really intriguing i must say i find
these oops not after that i was going to
say these knight endings
very very intriguing there's knight c6
knight takes b5 check the king can just
move
and the pawn on b4 is undefensible
so it looks like gregory is just
neutralized
and then joel will join nauthikov and
that typhoon first is we'll probably
have a number of people in two points
kaidonov it looks like wolf will join
him
and um yeah maybe just him
that sounds about right so i'll have two
people with two and a half and two with
two
now in this position i'd be reluctant to
play king e7
i think there might be a uh my
reluctance would be
stem from having to worry about a king
and pawn
end game where my opponent's king is
already
on my side of the board and that was why
we saw
king d7 by gregory good
clown let's get to the sharp crazy game
is the game between gurovich and wolf
and the variations we saw
are occurring 52 work f2 specific
variation we saw with
rook f2 on move 27 and it looks like you
have to take this rook i don't see
how you can even scream otherwise the
rook is going to be good
there is there is a possibility of king
g7h8
g2 and king f1 and knight g1 should stop
that
so i think he has to take the rope
although he is pondering it
30 seconds left for roll 40 seconds left
for dima
okay so rook f2 but i really like what
you did
so here i had some dreams of maybe
running for the hills
with rook g1 but i liked your queen h
there he is he's playing it and so does
patrick so you're channeling
uh you're you're you're former well
okay principal i guess so you're the
trainer
he's the principal right
too he's singing the whole line in king
h7
there just hit his head his hand was on
top of his head he
realized he missed this possibility but
now rook g1
trying to hang on hoping against hope
that looks like there's going to be some
checks
flying at them but then you've got this
sequence where you can force the king
to f1 and i think yeah so you had bishop
d4
bishop d4 before mm-hmm when the king
was not too i didn't
you didn't have to force him no back up
back up back up a move
not this position this one back up one
move where the queen's on a3
so you can yes so so king f1 and we're
seeing the line
yeah nice one checkpoint check on the h
right we're seeing it and it is king f2
now bishop
now bishop d4 oh that's too pretty
bishop d4 that that's like a
trap door that just closes a snap that
means now he has to play king e1 which
he has
done and the trade has occurred
after knight g1 look at that sad
night queen h1 played
queen h1 with the idea of bishop d4
and that must be the idea but i've got
i've got
he could have played queen g2 and zlatan
he played queen b6
he closed his own door c5 should kill
him
oh no oh my goodness and he's played
he could have played king f1 and and he
has the the chance
but now he's allowed this move c5 in
time pressure he had only two seconds
left
queen h1 was a real error it looks like
uh he could have just played something
direct like queen g2 no
and the knight is god was the one just
thinking about that
you just take everything that was
that was what i expected and look at
patrick
patrick like what the heck
he had you know this is the thing that
uh my colleagues just they love to do
they really do
is the moment the game is over they love
to go to the engine and find the truth
they want to know was i winning did i
make the
right move did i have the right
understanding
and instantly they moved uh sum up this
round for us uh uh jen because that was
quite an eventful finish that's right
well we got two players tied for the
lead
igor novakova who um be
won two games in a row winning against
shabbat love and gets
around two against goetz in round three
against shabala but then he's joined
by joel benjamin who um won his first
two games and then
drew against gregory kaiden i've tried a
little bit in that ending game
but couldn't get anywhere i might add
that joel has played
um gregory and shabalov already so
um two of the favorites
one might say although technically by
rating larry is the favorite he's not
doing so well so far guys he did draw
that game
against shelby getz so guess really well
with the black pieces
and we are with one of the classiest
gentlemen in all of us chess if not
world chess
my former trainer as well he helped me
on my road to becoming a grandmaster he
was a trainer that i had
so i thank him and i'm grateful for him
and i can call him a good friend
gregory welcome to the show thank you
can you hear me okay maurice yes we can
absolutely hear you
gregory your thoughts on playing this
this day online chess for the u.s
championship
did you ever think it would come to this
yeah of course yeah no nobody could
expect that so yeah you know i was
very nervous because obviously it was
the
first official uh online tournament for
me
uh okay let me disconnect
okay so this should be fine um
so i was very very nervous uh during the
first game
uh so it was
it was very very nervous situation but
amazingly
i did well yeah that was the game that
you won against patrick wolf with the
sacrifices
yeah i mean this is one of those
sacrifices which was kind of easy to
decide on because
uh you have a guaranteed draw right
and when we got close to this position
i looked at knight shake g6 and i saw
that
uh once again i'm not risking anything
um like for example if he moves queen
away queen b7
queen g5 check um
can get fade and of course rook h6
is probably the move but just in case
right but just in case i can play queen
h6
back and forth a draw when they had
queen f6
right so this is one of those
sacrifices which is easy to decide on
because you have
a guaranteed draw but
i saw rook h6 and uh
i was going to check it when when it was
getting closer
very practical sacrifice indeed good
game to win
your feeling about your other two games
um uh game against uh dmitry
was uh
nothing special in the sense that i i
felt like
i got a little better position after the
opening but you know
i felt he played very accurately and
uh this was one of those you know
grandmaster
draws which you know both sides
played well at least that's how i felt
uh i didn't see
any improvements for myself uh but game
against joel was very tough
yeah uh he got a slightly better
position right after the opening
and i was defending the whole game
and and the position was very difficult
yeah so i always was on the verge of
losing a pawn
and somehow i survived but uh
it was it was tough gregory
you have am i right into in saying this
and yasser was very shocked by it
but have you ever won a u.s
national title whether it be
no championship no i played 18
no i played 18 championships in a row
joel was worrying about his record
because his record is 21
but i could make it there so
21 in a row in a row yeah
yeah so what would it mean for you to
win this one
uh it would be nice but you know that's
not the same as winning a real
uh u.s championship um
moreover i i can tell you
something i never told anyone that
you know when i when i was in my 40s
i was watching those senior
championships you know world
championships and so forth
and i said to myself i'm never going to
play in the senior champion
no it's like it's below my dignity i
always will play in the real tournaments
regardless of how
well or bad level performer i will never
play senior championship
yeah but of course so why did you change
your mind championship in the sense that
you know it's basically a replay replay
of
one of the 1990s u.s championships right
right yeah yeah so playing
my friends and uh
rivals you know over you know we
what we probably played 15 years uh you
know
against each other so but um
it feels good to see them at the
chessboard
even though online this time
and play against them it's definitely
better to play online
than than not to play at all
that is really wonderful great sentiment
gregory thanks for joining us
always a class act uh good luck the rest
of the way
thank you gregory thank you good luck
never say never well he and he he pegged
it just
right that his sacrifices against
patrick were just
you know he wasn't taking risks he
always had to draw
and he he survived he survived this game
with joe benjamin he said that joe put a
lot of pressure on him
throughout but ironically kaidano won
against patrick in the first round and
that seemed to be the ideal warm-up for
patrick wolfe
and so he went on to win his next two
games as he has all decisive results so
far in this tournament
navakov and benjamin tied for first with
two and a half
kaidanov and wolff the only other two
players with a plus score and look at it
or even fifty percent exactly
but we do have the ever exciting
alexander chavalla
with us shabba in the building
alex we haven't seen each other in a
long time
uh how are you feeling right now my
friend it seems you had a tough day
today
didn't quite get what you wanted out of
the games
i'm not talking he's hearing us yet
because he doesn't seem like he's
responding to your
farming opening yes
i don't think he heard him yet i don't
think he is
uh maybe the there's i think there's
somebody who has contacted with him
we'll get back to shabba love
um but he uh yeah i mean what a small to
a say but
shavulab is just a player you love to
have in the tournament because every
time you look at his board
there's something exciting happening
unfortunately today
that only gave him one point out of
three
he flagged one game that was wild with
joel
and then he lost the game that really
wasn't him that just wasn't him against
novakov he contributed to the leaders
being where they are
they both got him today so
if not for shabala if we would have no
leaders to
that's true we had a couple of draws out
of those games
and but it actually is pretty crazy that
we only have four players
over 50 percent one of them being joel
benjamin
straight out of brooklyn let's see if we
get joel on and i know he's living in
new jersey right now
joel first of all can you hear us and
congratulations i can hear you yeah can
you hear me
yes we can hear you indeed joel you know
i brag about brooklyn of course
you know rep in brooklyn of course yeah
but
there you go and then i'd have to say
heart
palpitations today i mean you really did
it in those first two games
you had us all on the edges of our seats
with the time pressure
this particular game you have on board
when it ended i
i was like this i was i thought i was
gonna have a heart attack
we saw you holding your chest don't have
that on us
on air please at all at all but
what do you think do you think is just
getting getting informed getting in
shape
having not played rapid chess online
well it's like this the the elite
players in the world they they play this
time
this type of time control a lot and uh
they're really good at it and we look at
their games we analyze their games
like they're real games but us
us uh semi-retired guys
we don't play this i mean i never do so
it's very hard to
kind of find the right way to go about
it
and i know i'm taking too much time and
my opponents were taking too much
time and so the first two games just
you know descended into clock
so hopefully as we go on we'll get
better at it but uh
but you know the handling the clock was
very difficult
you did play a very solid game in the
last game however it looked like you had
some chances
i had good preparation but i'm pretty
sure it was just winning now
now i'm thinking about i think i should
have gone knight c7 knight a6
and come with the king probably yasser
had worked it all out
you know but i'm not as good an endgame
player as the offer
unfortunately at what at what moment
someone around these parts you you you
figured yeah joe yeah
he played 97 yeah knight f5
i think that was okay yeah
and after bishop f7 i have a real
dilemma because
i can't quite win the pawn directly but
i think i should i think that's probably
winning knight c7
knight a6
and now come with the king the king the
king gets to e3
in time and
i wasn't totally sure that he couldn't
get the c4 with the knight
maybe you know but i think i have time
to get my king to d4
yeah king e3
yeah the king gets a d4 but
unfortunately i see these things but i
make the wrong choice
i miss this night getting a six you know
the knight finding a nice passive square
you know
uh
and then it ended up only in a draw
right yeah unfortunately tonight is
the night is good enough there yeah
yeah definitely he was in some trouble
in this game
yeah you mentioned go ahead jen i wonder
if he could have played like king e7
knight f7 and then knight c4 check and
somehow saved it
it always going to be really like uh a
temple
game there but um did it seem that you
were resolved to play faster in this
game
did you feel like you had enough in the
first two games
last few seconds this was preparation
well it was preparation up until a half
until uh
because of the
knight takes b3 is not a good move
knight c4 is better
so i was really more ready more
expecting knight c4
i think that i think white has an edge
here after knight takes b3
right you were expecting knight c4
because if you if i see four i think
it's
yeah yeah yeah this is just better
hold on a second hold on a second can i
go back
yeah we go back up close because i could
have taken his rook first
yeah that's what jazz was looking at
first i think that wins the d-pawn
but but you can win the d-pawn and then
still not necessarily win the game with
rooks on the board
bishop e6 later i saw the move knight d
c6
i think that's strong i didn't see it at
the time
and that i think that just wins the pawn
but i'm not totally sure that
that is enough to win the game because
the b pawn is still my drop
definitely sharp position
yeah chances chances we're going to have
a lot more chances like that coming up
as you said you're playing against these
players
what does it feel like to be playing
gregory said it's like a 90s party
what does it feel like to be playing
against all these players that you
played for so many years
and you have the record of 21 u.s
championships in a row
now you're back with the old game i
think it's more than that but i kind of
lost track of myself
it's been been so long you know i think
i thought it was 23. but anyway
um it's great to play these guys you
know it's uh
it's it's a really it's it's a really
wonderful challenge and i
i you know i i love uh
you know i love seeing them play and i
love their
their artistry um although
i don't know if there was all that much
art today but
there was definitely struggle you know
there was definitely fight
and uh and that
kind of connection i
think yeah we it seems like we we might
have lost joel i hope we're still up but
um i i did confirm it was 26
actual um us championship appearances
for joel benjamin
and we have alex
hi alex shabba how are you
good yes sir hi how's coming
well alex
you you had a tough day today one
position
you lost on time the other one seems
like you mixed up your attacking moves
what happened
i yeah well against joel
uh i was just i don't know i was
sleeping in the end i thought i got like
more than 10 seconds for the last move
and when i
i think i spent two but somehow i lost
on time
so uh but probably by that by that
moment i already like
mixed things up and the position is not
that good anymore
well that was my impression so i just
didn't find the correct plan after
pretty decent opening i guess
so that's the first one uh
okay the the second game um
well i've played
something new because well we
uh we spent some time with like training
with yarmouth like played each other
before this tournament so
we knew each other really well what
we're going to be playing
and i just really wanted something that
we did not touch
yeah it turned out like well
uh it's a little crazy but interesting i
think with few games were played with
this
uh idea recently and not
that easy for black to find a
uh precise way to equalize if you don't
know it if you did not analyze it so i
go with the board
25 minutes well it didn't work for yama
here
okay and the the last one uh
yeah i think i took uh the prep took
uh igor by surprise but he found like a
nice safe way to
um to deal with it and
when i had a choice to play couple of
choices yeah
uh after king f2 there was e4
without leading the very interesting
position right
and of course after
yeah it's about equal and that's
something to fight
that's because what i did uh taken
and knight e5 was also good but i had to
find
uh bishop a6 instead of bishop d7 and
that just looks to me
why it has to force a draw after takes
take through q1
and rook h21 which is not a
simple move to play on yeah
i think when h4 and just to pick up the
pawn on h2
is good enough right uh
because he can't play king g1 because of
knight takes f3
and all right
so you have to play king f1
and i think quintex h2 f4
and qnh1 queen h4 is just perpetual
and this is the route blah had to go
uh but for some reason i thought that i
might be even winning with bishop d7 and
completely miss queen f4
it's just for some reason this square
did not register with me when i
uh looked at this position which looked
really really promising for black
so many threads so many checks from all
over the place but queen f4
just a refutation uh if not
for this move well you know
so this is it
this is how you score one out of three
we know if you're an optimistic person
your feelings about the next two days uh
well obviously i have to regroup to
recover and
probably go for less complicated
positions i mean
the bose against joel and the last one
turn out to be too much for me now i
mean maybe
on this time control i just have to go
for something simpler
like uh like with gun sierra mode the
position was like really
you know one two three and it's like
nothing to think about it but
this apparently was too complicated
hearing shabala and simple in the same
sentence
guys something about that bothers me
doesn't compute
doesn't compute i like the complicated
keep it complicated
uh doesn't mean simple i wish
all right we'll see if he keeps it to it
i don't think so guys
i think it's still going to be some
crazy java love games tomorrow
thanks alex good luck thanks for your
analysis and your good mood
we'll see you tomorrow see you thank you
guys
bye bye now and where do we stand jim
joel benjamin and igor navikov with two
and a half points
each and gregory kaidonov and patrick
wolf
just half a point behind with two points
but nobody with one and a half points so
we dropped down
um a whole point for um
six players who are shared um fifth
through 10.
what are the results that's kind of cool
because if the tournament ended here
everybody could say i finished in the
top half of the crosstable
exactly exactly nicely put
and we do have two more days of this u.s
senior championship action coming up
tomorrow around four through six and
then we finish it off
on monday october 19th with our final
three rounds and a potential playoff
by the way i should note ed gonzalez who
is
the trivia u.s championship trivia
genius he messaged me and said joel
played in 23 straight and
26 overall so that is the correct style
impressive that's a record that well
it's going to be very hard to break
yeah too i wonder how many nakamura's
played
now so far well we'll find out as
we have so much chess left for you two
more days of the u.s senior championship
then we have the women's and the us
chess championship so thank you for
joining us
for this championship october there's a
lot more to come
and we will see you tomorrow same time
same place
uschestchamps.com and we'll be starting
at 12
50 in st louis
thank you everyone good night
[Music]
you